Boom,
boom,
boom.
Four three,
two,
one
oh and the sweet,
sweet sound of amplified voices.
And my man shooter Jennings,
Gee man,
you look like you're supposed to wear
sunglasses.
Some dudes wear sunglasses,
you know,
like pitch,
get those sunglasses off,
but you,
you look like you're supposed to be
wearing sunglasses.
There is a point in time when I moved
here,
uh,
I remember well for a while they were a
prescription.
So I had an excuse for a long time that
I went back to contacts.
But there was a point in time when I,
I remember turning to my friend,
I was like 21,
and I was like,
I think I'm just going to keep them on
all the time and then it'll just be a
thing.
And that way I can just,
if I have to close my eyes and nobody
will notice or if I'm stoned,
nobody will notice.
When people get super famous like Jay z
famous,
they were um,
inside everywhere,
just so people don't catch a glimpse of
their eyes handed him a demo tape.
Can you start out like a scrub wearing
them then?
Then it's weird if you take them off,
you know.
Well it's a different thing in the black
community to um,
like a real cool black artist is just a
loud,
they're just allowed.
They can just do it.
Right,
right.
I mean I'd be disappointed if like I saw
Bob Dylan out somewhere and he wasn't
wearing them like Christoper retires and
all the time.
Yeah,
good fade too.
It's like black,
Brown,
white Kinda.
Yeah,
he fits right.
The fuck and conor Mcgregor,
he can wear them indoors.
Oh yeah.
Some dudes can where I'm endorsed by
warm and doors,
I'd be a Douche bag plus the kind of
where I where like you know,
fucking sport ones.
I have a couple pairs of those that look
cool.
Cool ass aviator tiny.
These are in Porsche's.
My Dad used to wear a porsches in like
9.9 I ran across their purple ones and I
was like,
I bought like four pairs and I keep
breaking them in is my last one.
Those are very dope.
Those are porsche design.
They make some dope shit.
They do.
I just used to think that they only made
cars and then uh,
I felt they make phones.
Did you know anything like a phone?
Oh yeah,
I saw it.
I've never don't they make,
didn't they make a blackberry for a
minute?
They think maybe made a blackberry and I
think they made another phone recently.
I would love to get one of those.
But it's a weird little design chop they
have.
It is a walway phone.
I'm,
I'm saying it wrong apparently people
correct me.
Huawei,
Paul.
While ways a Chinese company that
actually just got busted because their
newest advertisement,
it shows them taking selfies,
but there aren't really taking selfies.
They use only a super high end dslr
camera that to take the photo and
they're passing it off as if these
people were just holding it up,
taking selfies.
It's on a fucking tripod,
the whole deal.
You get a photo of that,
look at that look,
look,
look guys holding it up as if he's
taking a selfie.
But meanwhile there's a fucking
professional doom the tripod.
But he's making it look like he took
that picture.
Who busted then?
Ah,
I think the woman in the photo busted
them cause I think she took pictures or
had someone take pictures of the photo
shoot.
Yeah.
You gotta look on her
face like that too.
She's really,
come on.
Wow.
Way Burmese.
Meanwhile,
here's what's stupid about that.
They don't have to do that.
Those goddamn things take amazing
selfies.
That's a great phone.
Like the,
the newest,
latest smartphones.
They take incredible selfies.
I know,
but people never satisfied with the
truth.
This is why people,
gorgeous women.
We'll put those fucking crazy cartoons.
They'll selfie filters on.
Yeah,
they're beautiful.
And then they'll,
they'll turn themselves into a cartoon.
Like you don't get it.
Like you're supposed to have pores,
right.
We don't mind pores.
I don't mind the wrinkles in your skin
when you smile.
I don't mind.
You know,
the,
the bubbles of saliva on your teeth.
Okay.
Would,
and people are getting this weird state
of mind where they think they're so,
you know,
they,
they said there's an epidemic of girls
like insta models that are actually
getting surgery to try to look like they
look in their selfies.
Oh my God.
You know,
speaking of instant models,
I just listened to David spades audio
audio book,
which I thought was great.
The uh,
I guess what polaroid guy in a snapchat
world or whatever and there's a lot of
chapters that deal with the incident.
I don't even realize,
I didn't even realize this is the thing
like adding dude,
I am so out of the loop with,
with,
do you go to instagram?
Do you,
do you like pay attention to it?
He just post pictures occasionally.
Man,
I,
I'm not really good at paying attention
to any of it.
Twitter from day one I kind of was in
and I'll go in and out,
but it's hard for me to actually keep up
and care about it.
Like I hate posting pictures of myself
and my manager Adam is here.
He's always like,
dude,
if you're going to post something on
Instagram,
just make sure you're in it or
something.
Cause I'm always like taking pictures of
other people can listen to that dude.
That's ridiculous.
You can't,
you're not supposed to be in every
picture you take.
That's crazy.
I know,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm bad at it and I'm very bad at caring
about other people's pictures too.
And it's like,
like my wife will be like,
I just posted on instagram so I got to
go like it.
Oh,
that's annoying you to talk to her
about.
Her pictures are good.
So I'm,
I'm sure they're great,
but God damn do I have to double tap
each and every one of them just give you
the nod.
It looks good now we'll see.
See,
it's easy to throw that off and see.
My daughter is now,
he's 10 now as an instagram account and
if I'm not liking them,
I feel horrible.
I'm like,
I've got my wife's already like him.
yeah,
I think that's a lot of pressure for a
kid.
It will serve as are all pictures of
these lol dolls that she's obsessed with
anyway.
And slyly slime was a new one,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Fucks all that comment by the way.
It's fidget spinners out.
Yeah.
I just find out,
I mean my son got so obsessed with
fidget spinners and my daughter,
but really my son to the point where
like they were spending some time in New
York and I'd be gone up there and we
walked down the street and like every
fucking vendor,
every newsstand stand,
every like pretzel place had like fidget
spinners and like I'd have to buy it,
you know,
it'd be like,
he'd be like,
Ooh,
that one has a skull on it and be like,
okay,
and it's like 10 bucks and then to spend
just a right,
that guy in sense to manufacturer in
Taiwan,
he was like an 18 year old kid who came
up with that and he wanted to be an
entrepreneur and he made that.
Now he's like a billionaire.
How did he figure that out?
Like I want to talk to that dude.
Go,
hey man,
shit damn on the show.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't give out the secret,
but what the fuck is next?
I didn't see slime coming either.
My daughters have fucking gallons of
glue and and,
and,
and chargers.
Yeah.
Just yesterday,
my daughter and son were making slime
with it and I'm,
I was saying the same thing.
I'm like,
man,
I mean we had like ectoplasm slime and
nickelodeon slime when I was a kid and
like all but it was not like this.
All of a sudden it's like,
uh,
I can't believe it.
And you watch the commercials for glue.
They have glow in the dark glue and
they're like showing a kid making slime
with the elmer.
No.
Talk about an unexpected boost for
elmers chat.
They must have jumped.
He wants to jump on tide.
They came up timers between tide pods
and the slime tides like fucking real.
What people really eating detergent
real,
I guess that seems like it would be
unbelievably bad for your body to eat a
detergent.
We used to huff like Scotch guard when
we were kids or Potpourri.
I mean maybe it's a smell.
Markers.
Yeah.
I used to love the smell of like a good
sharpie,
like a fat one.
Do the thing in school for you where
they grab you and they,
they pull you up and then you almost
pass out and then they let you go.
And we used to do that in elementary
school where they,
yeah.
What was the,
how'd that work?
I think I would get behind these.
You pick it up and then she told you or
some shit.
Yeah,
until you can't basically breathe.
You're almost suffocating and then let
you go and then you're like,
hi.
Hi.
Yeah,
I don't know.
The kids are always trying to,
well,
even monkeys,
man.
I mean,
animals try to change their state,
you know,
they,
they think it's just a natural thing.
The creatures tried to change your
state,
change your state of consciousness.
Even little kids.
But I wonder about that slime stuff
because I genuinely,
genuinely worry.
Like people I don't think had been
dealing with large volumes of glue and
detergent like that with the physicals
too.
That's another one.
Oh yeah.
Borax is,
yeah.
That's fucking toxic.
You think gets in your skin is an organ.
People don't realize that.
You don't think about that when you
spray it on all the different shit that
people put on their bodies.
Like I think about that when I use
sunscreen.
I'm like,
what is this stuff right here?
You're blocking your pores with some
Goo,
some good.
Well,
it's also your,
your skin's absorbing it.
Like,
um,
like when you go in that isolation tank,
that's one of the best ways to absorb
magnesium because of the epsom salts.
Like when you float around in the tank,
the epsom salts,
you know,
your,
your body absorbs magnesium from talking
about altered states.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Have you done that before?
I still haven't done dmt.
We had that conversation.
That's right.
We haven't had a conversation about how
the fuck have we only done one other
podcasts together.
That's ridiculous.
You know,
we live in the same town.
I know.
We went,
we had a great dinner.
It was dirty.
It was fun.
My mom.
Yeah.
That was really fun.
I got the Great Mrs Rogan out.
Yeah,
that's right.
It was fun.
We had a good time.
Do that.
Places the shit a place like you go back
in time.
That is my,
that is the spot where if they,
I feel like I've made it in this town.
If they know me by name there and I can
always get a spot at the bar.
I'm close.
They know me by name,
but I don't always have a spot at the
bar.
Um,
you can,
I don't think anybody always gets a
spot.
The Pars Woods does.
Oh,
does he?
I bet he's got a giant Dick.
I here.
Sweet.
I bet it seems like it.
I finally met him there.
I had the balls to walk up to him one of
the recent times and I was like,
hey man,
you know,
you just got to walk up with the Hillary
Clinton joke.
I love video drowned.
He's a Republican now.
Yeah,
but he's,
he's,
he's funny.
I mean,
regardless of what side you're on,
he is just always on fire with that and
he,
he likes doing it just to aggravate
people.
Yeah.
Well he see,
it seems like he's done with the whole
acting thing,
right.
He,
I said he invested in apple in the 80s
and he's fine with being blacklisted.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what he said.
He bought it.
Made a tweet or something like that.
The investment in Apple.
Yeah.
Interesting.
That's how weird is that?
You can just say,
I think this company is going to kick
some ass.
We by piece.
Yeah.
I think you'd get a piece of a company
and then they become the apple.
Apple apparently has a more than a
trillion dollars now.
I know that and then insane.
That's kind of dangerous.
Anybody to have that kind of influence
though with these phones and shit.
It's like that's pretty,
pretty dangerous.
I kind of trust them with data though.
I feel like even with they're trying to
deal.
Yeah.
Well Google has a weird trying to deal
to,
will they also have secret servers in
North Korea and shit?
Yeah.
Well I mean they just have servers set
up and all these other countries.
All of that up danger cause I didn't
trust any of them.
What are they doing in north?
I don't know.
Dick Pics Rovers full of,
I think there's all kinds of networks
that had been going on for years that
are involved in shit.
I think I like I was,
I,
I tell my friends or my drummer
specifically I talked to,
but I was like,
man,
I think I like,
I'm not a rich guy,
but like I think that there's a point of
money that I would be,
I would like to know the threshold in
which you get past that and then like
the Saudis and then all the,
all these people start coming in wanting
a part of you and then you start selling
your soul.
Like whatever that is.
If it's 5 million bucks,
I just got to stay right there.
That would be,
I don't want to get richer than that.
Once you have influence,
I think it's,
it becomes a scary world.
So I like,
I think there's a lot of concern with
people wonder whether or not someone's
been like,
I've been accused of being approached
like that of my cia acid or that I,
here's a big one.
I think really the flat earth.
Oh,
the flat earth people,
they think that,
uh,
I've been approached to talk about the
earth being round to be around round
Earth shill.
Jamie started selling tee shirts.
Round Earth Shale.
James got round earth.
She'll tee shirts and he
sells@youngjamie.com man,
I mean around
or the shield shell is like saying like,
you know that the Reptilian people went
to you to be a human shill.
All someone told me that,
someone told me that they believe that
there's reptilians underneath the earth
and that they have a car.
They've carved tunnels through the
ground with laser beams and to have like
a network of tunnels they use,
they,
they travel amongst us,
waiting for their time to expose
themselves.
People believe like you see someone like
safe.
You live in an apartment building and he
tried by a dude's house,
got a fat house.
You Go,
wow,
that guy's got a fat house.
I wonder,
wonder who he knows.
I wonder if he's like he's in with the
mob or maybe he's deep with the
Democrats or maybe he's the bankers or
Cusco.
Who's he?
Who does he know?
Because you always think of like someone
like being like at a level where you're,
you're you like they sit you in a room
and they give you some communications
that you're not supposed to expose to
the rest of the world.
Right.
Well,
I mean there is again,
what I,
what I was saying about the threshold of
money.
There is a point and you know it's there
in which in,
I mean Google started with a couple of
dudes who were like,
we got this idea.
There was before that there was a thing
called web crawler.
That was kind of the first experience
of,
of me of a search engine that I'd ever
experienced.
Whether there was netscape navigator,
wasn't,
wasn't one of those,
netscape navigator was a,
was one of the first Brazil's browser.
Yeah,
there was a mosaic and netscape
navigator,
but there was a way to search that was
web crouther.
Lycos came later who came later,
but there was web crawler.
Danielle who and like us and then Google
never ask jeeves.
Yeah.
Cool.
Asked Jesus real thing has.com is still
there.
It's still there.
But,
uh,
but like,
you know,
you gotta look a couple of dudes in an
office,
Hey,
we got a web search and then all of a
sudden they're,
they've got con,
I mean,
Amazon has cia contracts that's known
because they use their servers to do
things.
You got,
you got to look,
Amazon has like super,
super secure servers,
but there's still been hacked.
They're as secure as anyone else's.
They just have,
once you make that,
I think it's the,
maybe it's 500 million,
there's gotta be a mark.
Yeah.
There's a number of ways in which people
start approaching you and saying,
hey man,
you've got too much influence.
Would you like to join our group and
we'll support you and you'll make a
billion.
Ooh.
And she's level.
Yeah.
I was in Italy.
I just got back and uh,
we,
uh,
took a boat from um,
from the Amalfi coast,
took a boat from a mall free to Capri,
which is an island house.
Gorgeous Matte.
But when you're there,
you see the crazy yachts.
Like Steve Jobs has a yacht.
Wow.
That he had built before he died and now
his family owns it.
Leo Dicaprio and Bella Hadid and his,
his yacht looks like an apple store.
It's the craziest thing.
I mean we,
we,
we drove right by it.
Yachts are weird too because they're
worth like a hundred million bucks,
but you could basically look,
drive up and smack it like no one has
done.
There's,
it's weird.
I mean that's how pirates work,
right?
You can just hop onto the,
throw a grappling hook up and they climb
on top of your yacht,
but we're driving by,
he's got smack it.
He's kind of,
there it is.
That's it.
Wow.
It's a floating apple store that I don't
want to have to deal with that and the
maintenance and everything.
I'm fine.
I would rather just just first class it
and a and go to,
you know,
go on a trip and maybe rent that yacht
for like,
if I had the money to do it,
even renting that I would be like a half
a million dollars a week.
Oh fuck that.
I'll just get a boat and go up to it and
write it on.
The difference between the experience in
a boat,
that big and an experience at a boat
that's like a fraction of that science
is not that different.
Like that's pretty fucking awesome.
But ultimately it's like a Ho like
that's there.
You get a good impression of what it's
like.
It's,
it doesn't,
it doesn't really do it justice in an
image because it's so,
it's so modern,
right?
Like,
uh,
when you,
when you get near it,
it's so strange looking.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
it'd be awesome to party on that for
like a week.
It'll be the best of it would suck.
Look at that boat that just pulled right
up.
Hey Man.
Yo Steve,
my fucking eye pads,
bro.
Dude,
my fucking ipad just broke.
I mean,
I don't know man.
He,
did he ever ride it?
No,
he,
he shit the bed before he wrote it.
You know what's really fascinating,
I read something about he died of
pancreatic cancer and one of the things
he did was he drink fruit juice every
day and we used to think the fruit juice
is really good for you,
right?
You're drinking fruit now they say,
no,
no fruit.
It was really good for you.
But drinking fruit juices is kind of an
unnatural state.
There's no fiber in that.
So you're just drinking straight sugar
and now they say that drinking like a
glass of fresh squeezed orange juice has
the same sugar as drinking a can of
soda.
So you really,
your body doesn't differentiate much
between chemicals and soda though
chemicals are not good,
right?
Some chemicals,
but some of them,
they're innocuous.
Like you could drink,
like I was reading something about like
diet coke,
like someone was saying like Diet Coke
give you brain cancer.
And that's her saying that it prevents
cancer.
What they're there.
There was an article I read recently
that was saying that they thought that
Diet Cola is actually helped it.
They flipped their a script on that too.
They have a little fast talk at the end
of it.
It's
dot spots.
Those fucking,
first of all,
that fast talk shit should be illegal.
I don't know why that's not illegal.
Remember they used to do that at the end
of those goddamn commercials,
they hire somebody who talks like a
carnival barker.
Whole commercial like that.
That'd be awesome man.
Yeah.
Make it all ineffective here.
What does that,
um,
could die.
Coke help curb colon cancer's return.
What?
Diet coke?
Who fucking see new study shows that
Colin can,
here's the problem,
man.
Fucking studies dude.
Studies are a problem because you,
you can get like there was a study
posted recently.
It was a,
a questionnaire that showed that people
who eat higher carb diets live longer,
but it's,
it's basically a questionnaire that over
20 something years of like what you eat
and then the people who died,
like there was all sorts of problems
with it.
Like they didn't exercise as much.
They were fatter than the people who ate
more carbs.
And also you're asking people to
remember what they ate,
which is like very,
very ineffective.
And then the same cup,
the same place,
put out a study,
um,
really recently that showed the exact
opposite effect.
And so it's like,
well,
what the fuck if I'm just a regular guy
who barely has time to read the paper
and I read a study every now and then,
it's basically like what you catch,
you can catch some second ausas found
that about half of the benefit appear to
be due to people switching from regular
to diet sodas.
Oh,
so the colon cancer was really just,
you stopped drinking coke.
Coke was giving you colon cancer.
So now diet coke,
coke prevents colon cancer.
It's really,
no coke gives you fucking colon cancer.
Right?
It's so hard to know.
It's so hard to know,
man.
I try to keep up.
I cannot,
I try now.
That's the problem with the Internet and
everything.
Back in the day when we just didn't know
shit at,
seems like things move smoother,
you know?
Yeah.
But you remember like,
people thought all kinds of goofy shit.
Like thought most of your diet should be
bread.
I would that food pyramid and took his
rib out is on deck now.
But that was her.
That was a rumor back in the day.
The city,
no,
I met him.
He might do,
might actually do that.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
that was one.
How about here's the granddaddy of all
rumors,
Richard Gere and that dribble terrible.
Everybody knew that.
How is that possible?
I want to drum up your ass.
Ho It's possible.
My Buddy Steve did his residency in
Miami.
He's a ophthalmologist and he told me
that they pulled all kinds of things
that a dude's buts and you know,
those uh,
kind of fic lightening,
uh,
those thick a light bulbs that look like
a,
like a tree,
like a Christmas tree,
right?
Yeah.
Some dude shoved one of those up,
his asshole and it broke watch,
uh,
the,
who is America yesterday?
I haven't watched a single episode of,
I love it.
I love that show by the way.
I'll do that.
You know,
there was a lot of,
there was a lot of talk about it and not
think it was great what he did.
I mean,
all he did was he set up people to,
to show the ugly people if,
if they had it.
But I did not see that episode.
Please.
A genius man,
man.
I went real quick story.
I was like,
there's a band called Hell Down Glory
that I've loved for years and the lead
singer and lead were virgil.
They live in Reno.
And so he took me to Reno on the,
I'd been Rena before,
but he took me on the hell bound glory
tour of Reno,
uh,
which was him going to different bars
and shit.
And he took me to this guy's house and
it was,
it was a friend of his lived down the
street and they was like,
their garage was open and a bunch of
people hanging out playing vinyls in
this dude and drinking,
you know.
And at some point this guy was like,
hey,
I got show you something.
And he reached into his ceiling light.
He had like one of these but not what
the,
the uh,
uh,
clouds on it.
It was just a regular like light and you
pull out and he had up in there,
he had an x ray that he pulled out and
it was an x ray of a woman's vagina with
a flying v Guitar neck that the head
stock in,
in it.
It was an x ray of that.
So it got stuck.
I mean,
I don't know how,
I mean with the fucking tuning pegs and
everything,
but it was,
it was a,
so,
you know,
oh,
can you believe coming out?
Yeah.
I mean,
how can we,
going in
woman's vagina is remarkably flexible
thing.
They make babies,
babies come out of their bodies.
Yeah.
But I mean that's a whole hormonal
thing.
Their body sets up for nine months to
let happen.
I mean,
just sticking,
maybe she really loves music.
Oh Man.
Maybe she really,
really,
really loves hair metal and went there.
Maybe it's just a giant fan of slayer
wants that once that guitar in her body.
Woo.
But my friend Steve said he,
they pulled all kinds of things out of
people's bodies and uh,
he said he saw he was in Miami and he
said that it was during the cocaine days
when I met steering the cocaine days.
Like they ended,
oh yeah,
that's over bro.
That's like,
so 1980.
Uh,
but he was there during the eighties,
seventies and the 80s.
That's when I met him.
Okay.
I was in high school when I met him.
Um,
so I think I was 15 or 16.
Where'd you go to high school?
Newton south high in Newton,
Massachusetts.
A suburb of Boston.
How'd you meet him?
A taekwondo.
And he was,
uh,
he was,
doing his residency for ophthalmology
and uh,
I was a young high school kid who was
competing and so it's all,
I was over there every day.
So if you came there,
he saw me.
And um,
he,
uh,
so he was doing his residency in Boston.
He was a,
he was finishing it up in Boston,
but he had done some of his work before
that in Miami.
So this was,
I graduated in 85 so he was probably
Miami,
like 80,
81,
somewhere around.
Then he just got back.
He showed me all kinds of pictures,
dude.
Wow.
This is back before the Internet.
I got to see brains,
people's brains hanging out.
You showed me some photos of bullet
holes with a polaroid or something.
Take question.
I Dunno.
I don't remember.
Dubious.
Dubious there.
Well,
people were dead.
You know,
the brains,
they were dead.
I didn't get to see like the,
the light bulb up the asshole.
He didn't have to pay.
Hey man,
stay still while you're screaming.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But uh,
distract him.
But he legitimately did have some photos
of some atrocious things,
but he said it was just to go from being
a medical school school student to doing
your residency in Miami and just seeing
just crazy amounts of violence.
He said it was just insane.
Like if you seen cocaine cowboys,
I have not.
Oh my God.
Billy Corbin,
who's been on the,
maybe made two of the most amazing
documentaries ever.
That's about the blow air on cocaine.
I mean,
uh,
the movie blow and all that.
George [inaudible],
George hung or whatever.
Well,
no,
it was,
how about Grizelda Griselda Blanco.
Who is this a bad ass bitch from
Columbia?
Was she from Columbia?
Bogota?
Yes.
That was the Miami Shit when I think I
saw part of that documentary,
but I always wanted to watch it.
Oh,
it's so good.
It's so,
he's getting,
just got two of them,
so if you,
you do it,
you got to fucking get together.
Docent,
cocaine cowboys to why?
Fuck around with a crazy,
hard to remember a cql name,
but a cocaine cowboys one and two.
Oh my God.
It's that.
There was one year where everyone who
graduated from the police academy either
was murdered or went to jail.
Every single graduate.
Wow.
Was either killed because they had a
part,
a part of the cocaine business or a,
they went to jail for being corrupt.
Wow.
All of them.
There's more pay.
I don't know if this is true,
please google this.
There.
There were at least at the time,
more banks per capita in Miami than
anywhere else in the country because it
was all use to launder cocaine money.
Wow.
Yeah.
No Bullshit,
man.
Again,
man,
you get that level of money as he
started getting banks and stuff.
I'm just saying those two documentaries,
I can't say enough good things about
them.
They're so good.
It sounds exhausting.
Not the documentaries,
but the actual business of doing it.
Well.
That's why you need coke and new coke
while you were in that sense,
get high on your own supply,
man.
That's the only way to keep up with the
young kids.
I mean,
if you guys,
Rick Ross,
which one?
The real one or the fake one?
The rapper freeway.
Ricky.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
the real Rick Ross.
I know.
There's the freeway,
ricky.
Yeah,
that's the one you want to ask.
You don't want to ask the wrapper.
The wrapper was a prison guard.
Do you know that?
Yes.
Well,
you know freeway,
ricky who's been on the show a couple
times,
sued to get his name back and just to
keep his dude from using his name
because he was actually Rick Ross.
That's his actual fucker.
Ne Story.
I didn't know he was on your show,
Dude.
He's been on twice.
Rick Ross freeway.
Ricky was the guy who was selling all
the cocaine that paid for the contras
when the contracts are fighting the
Sandinistas in Nicaragua and that whole
aura north shit course freeway.
Ricky was the one who was selling all
the coat to these people.
He didn't know how he's getting these
coke.
He didn't know.
He was actually getting it deep,
deep,
deep state telling you,
I'm telling you to find the threshold.
And he learned,
he learned how to read and it's a great
style.
Ricky learned how to read in jail and
then learn how to become a lawyer in
jail and then realize they tried him for
a,
they did.
They hit him with three strikes,
but they hit him with two charges at the
same time,
which is not how three strikes work.
So you went to jail for life and then
got released for time for time served
because they tried him incorrectly.
Oh right.
It's okay.
Just one of be strikes was in exactly
one of his strike.
There were there were at the same time,
you can't do that.
It has to be like you go to jail,
you come out,
you go to jail again,
you come out and go to jail again and
go,
all right,
you're a criminal and then they keep you
in jail.
That was a high idea,
which is fucked up man.
Hey,
what's it like sitting across the table
from him?
He's a very nice guy.
Very smart guy.
He was a tennis player,
man.
Played tennis in Compton.
Yeah.
Couldn't fucking read men,
couldn't read,
played tennis and Compton and was just
seeing all these people around him that
were making crazy amounts of money.
Wow.
And is a real calm,
nice guy.
And that's one of the reasons why he did
so well said.
He wasn't this crazy buckwild do drive
and rolls royces,
throwing money out the window.
He wasn't that guy.
He was like the cool,
calm,
collected John Wick sort of character
that kept his shit together,
you know,
and everybody respected him because of
that.
He just was like,
you mean the same reason why he learns
how to be a lawyer while he's in prison?
He's a systematic,
you know,
intelligent dude who just had a shit
education,
you know,
just grew up in a very bad,
scary,
dangerous environment and you know,
didn't even learn to read until the guts
in jail in Lincoln,
the history of the Iran contra
conspiracies on lake got cocaine.
He was the guy that figured out how to
sell this shit and wow.
It was selling coke and didn't even know
who he was selling it for.
Didn't know that the people he was
selling it for like the,
the,
the contacts that he had were directly
supplied by the Oliver North,
the Bush and yeah.
Wow.
Interesting man.
I used to have oliver north for
president t shirt.
I wore it just to piss people off.
I didn't even know what it meant.
I was like 17 or something.
Shit.
Oh man,
that's not,
ah,
yeah man.
It's a,
the whole thing is crazy that this rick
Ross guy,
the rapper was actually a prison guard.
There's a photo of him was fucking
prison guard uniform on.
Wow.
I mean I like him a lot.
I ran across the web.
Are,
do I liked that big songs a lie on
what's the big st the better now the big
single,
I don't know.
I do one big one that I've sang before.
What's the record with a Dell is a lie
on it.
That was a record that I loved.
What's his big hit?
Me and Manton hanging out a lot and we
listened to Rick Ross all the time.
That's like really?
Yeah,
because gets to get together.
Do Code.
I mean,
I mean the nights,
right?
Uh,
no.
A bit like a that,
yeah,
like I liked the rick Ross guy that was
going to come in,
but he wouldn't do it on camera.
It was weird.
Like you wouldn't do it after he wanted
to do it.
They'll do it at a certain time of
night.
But so here's the thing,
man.
Some of that shit is publicists cause
I'll tell you the same thing happened
with Liz phair who I'm a giant fan of
hundred percent.
I've been a fan of Liz phair for Andrew
and exile in Guyville was fucking
fantastic.
Fucking loverage record and evil empire
at the same time at the record store
in Nashville,
Tennessee.
That Reggie's machine and Exxon guy.
Totally.
My wife also miss who we went near with
WHO's listing.
She loved Liz phair too at the time she,
she came and we got high together.
She's like,
you can get high here.
I'm like,
yeah,
I don't have a boss.
Alex Jones got high as fuck on high.
That was fucking awesome.
He's trying to come back on and I just
don't know if I could do it.
Oh come on,
let him come on.
They're fucking socks up them down.
They are shutting them down.
But the problem is he still on trial
this,
this whole trial that's going on with
the Sandy Hook and all that shit has to
be resolved for us.
But it doesn't mean like Bill Maher
respect to Bill Maher.
I respect him for saying he gets to
speak to,
he was on his show and people were
clapping and cheering that he was pulled
off of these networks and pulled off of
everything.
He's like,
look,
this guy has said crazy lies about me is
what Bill Maher said.
He said to the guy said crazy lies about
me.
He goes,
but he still gets to talk like this is
what America is about.
Free speech means all speech.
But see like,
here's what I don't understand.
Like Alex had me on many times and he
supported my record.
Black ribbon sort of Cayman.
Yeah.
You've been on the Alex Jones show many
times.
I've been,
I've been on it three times.
Where you ever sober?
Yeah.
Every time.
Doesn't show sober.
I've never,
I,
it was never a situation.
Well,
the first time I was,
uh,
we have the black ribbons record that I
did as Steven King and stuff like,
so when that record came out,
nobody would support the record.
So Alex and things on your record.
Yeah,
older record from what I do,
he plays,
he plays a Dj or a radio talk show hosts
that comes in and out of the record.
Um,
Stephen King.
Yeah,
as Stephen King.
So like when I did that record,
Alex Jones is the only person that would
support the record.
He put it,
he,
he debuted the whole record on his show
and then I went,
it was on for two hours by phone and
then I went in and was on his show in
person,
uh,
about just the music business.
That's all we were talking about and
like kind of how things were.
And then later I was on for bitcoin
discussion kind of,
um,
by skype or something.
But I will say this in his defense in
all of this,
I just think that like,
dude,
that guy has been saying things,
conspiracy theories about all kinds of
things.
What do you want?
Call him that or not?
They'd like forever.
And like now the,
the situation is like so volatile that
like they're going to,
you know,
the sandy hook thing.
All right.
So like they definitely caught fucking
Anderson Cooper having the green screen
and it's probably because they had
another person.
They're talking to the mom and then they
know what happened.
There's a video of Anderson Cooper
interviewing one of the moms from Sandy
Hook and he walked,
he leans a little too far forward and
his nose disappears and it's probably
because they had a standing report or
talking to the mom and what Anderson
Cooper was then like,
uh,
put in via,
you know,
whatever crane and like you kind of need
to see that is there,
I mean,
I know this is where we're propelling,
but my point is,
is like,
and I'm not,
I mean sandy hook,
I remember where I was when I heard
about sandy hook and it was horrific.
And I don't believe for a second that
there's like,
it's all fake or anything like that.
But like Alex's thing has always been
that I remember watching him go to
Bohemian Grove and when we did the
fucking record on,
this is back when nobody was paying
attention to them.
It just certain small group.
But I remember we did the black ribbons
record and we took a clip of the
laughing.
He went,
he snuck into Bohemian Grove and film
the ceremony and there like a scene
where they were not a scene.
I get the scene in his film,
but there's a part of that where they're
doing the ceremony and they have this
light.
It's like Disneyland when you go well
look to our God.
Yeah,
yeah.
But it's like,
it's done in a way where it's like
Disneyland when you watch like the
ferries fly around the castle.
Like there was a whole thing where there
was like a laugh that happens at the end
of the MOLEC thing or whatever.
Or the big Al and the,
and the funeral pyres drove.
So druids,
right.
So like I used a part of that,
but I remember watching that documentary
and he,
you know,
his deal has always been so over the top
where like you go,
he's like,
where are the,
he like,
go to the local people aren't near
Bohemian Grove.
He's like,
we're looking for where the Satan,
it's go to go do the thing,
you know?
And it's obviously at this point,
it's not like people who are knowingly
satanist.
It's like really old fat rich guys that
go there and there's probably hookers
and all kinds of shit because that's
what happens at big rich things,
especially in the nineties I mean,
so he get away with it.
You're right.
And so like now with all this,
and they're crucifying him,
especially pointing especially the Megan
Kelly thing,
and I just feel bad for it.
I mean,
especially the Manga because that was
clearly a hidden piece with Alex because
like they,
she buddied up to him and then then
focus that piece on the sandy hook
thing.
You know,
they had their talk in her defense,
how could she not?
Of course she's got us if you're going
to come,
if I was going to come,
but if I came here with the,
with the intention of like just talking
to you and then all of a sudden you were
like,
hey,
on this day on this thing,
when you did this thing,
like you focused on this one thing,
now it'd be like,
Oh man,
like this is a hit piece.
Like,
yeah,
but you're a musician and he's,
this is what he does.
I know my friend,
he's been my friend since 1999.
I get more shit from being friends with
Alex Jones and anything in my life
because actually,
you know what I'm just saying like,
I'm sure I'll get hit for this,
but the point is,
is that point check checker twitter,
I'm ready for it.
I don't,
you know what,
I don't have time to check it maybe next
year,
but like,
um,
but the reality is I just think that,
and I'm not even here from like the side
of the political point of view is this
is this,
watch this video was the video.
It says d quality Anderson Cooper's
disappearing,
knows Greenstein clip debunked.
See that?
Hold on.
Do you see what it says was debunked?
Which means happens.
Uh,
hold on,
let,
I'm sorry,
wasn't bad.
Quality video right here.
It'll play about three seconds.
Then there's a,
it,
there's a weird part on his nose that
happens.
But to say it's a green screen,
I would just,
I would tell the same,
the same people that are looking for
conspiracies and everything.
They use this to say that the space
station didn't exist.
Right,
but hold on.
Stick right around right there.
Hold on some and you can't even really
see it.
It's something really happened to those
super quick.
It looks like it was.
It was just like a digital glitch.
That's it.
No,
that's not it.
And this is what they said.
I couldn't find it anywhere else.
The other piece he leans forward is no,
look,
here's what I think.
I think that they had a stand in because
he couldn't be there,
but hold on.
You might be wrong,
right?
I could be.
This is,
we're talking about several years ago
you might have been fucked up memory
this.
Let's try to find the video that said he
was there all week shooting from the
exact same location.
Maybe it was,
maybe I'm wrong.
Got You.
They got to you.
Shooter Jennings.
I would say the same thing.
You know,
you make more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year.
Dude knocks on your door and starts
talking to you about conspiracy.
Well,
if you make it $34,000 a year,
you look at people to make 100,000 like
damn,
you had to pick all my fucking bills and
he gets to that hundred thousand dollar
level.
Well you got to sell out son.
But that's how people look at it.
But there is a threshold.
There is a threshold.
I remember when I was broke,
I had an a suburban.
I wasn't broke but it was,
I was doing it right but I had a
suburban and some guy and I got into a
fucking road rage situation on the
highway and he goes,
you fucking rich asshole.
I go rich [inaudible]
driving a fucking suburban man.
Like what is rich to you?
Rich is driving a suburban fine ma'am.
I have that like I already had the rich
thing because people thought that I was
rich because my dad,
which I never really,
I never was.
I mean he was supportive of me,
but once I got here it was,
I was Kinda on my own and I liked that.
But then then once I talk about bitcoin
with you,
like fucking five years ago or whenever
it was,
I was here three years ago and
everyone's like,
oh,
you gotta be rich now.
Cause that was like I can not rich coin.
Yeah.
But I mean look,
what's the point up til like seven grand
now.
Yeah.
It went up to 19 zero seconds.
Keep going down.
It hadn't dropped very much below six
grand.
But I mean when I was here with you it
was like less than a grant.
But um,
you know what I'm trying to say about
this is not like I'm not validating his,
this Anderson Cooper thing,
but that dude has always been fishing
for things like that and it's always
been his gig and it's been as Gig from
columbine.
It's been as Gig from all of this.
And I understand that the passion and
the emotion involved with the children
that died in sandy hook.
And I have no,
I'm not defending him on that deal.
But at the same time,
that's always been this guy's Gig.
I feel like dad is where he legitimately
fucked up.
I don't think if you take,
you take away,
I got to defend him.
I just can't say to fucking fuck up.
Yeah,
but this
is a silly fuckup he's saying that for
sure it was a fake,
but did he say for sure it's a Aa did
people sent me the clip?
They sent me the clip of him saying that
it was 100% fake.
He thought it was fake.
So he said it,
but he thought it was fake.
Yeah,
he thought it was a,
he thought it was a false flag.
So he said it.
I mean,
but that's part of them.
That's a part of the conspiratorial
thinking.
That's a real problem.
It's like saying,
you know,
he said some shit about me.
He said said some shit about me and it's
100% not true.
He said that the post your interview
with them,
I don't remember.
I think it was post,
it was post.
He said that the government threatened
my family to stop talking about
conspiracy theories.
No,
no.
Nobody threatened my family.
No one zero never happened.
Did Not happen.
It is fake.
It is a lie.
Someone told it to him,
I guess,
or he says someone told to him.
Okay,
it didn't happen.
There's so,
that's me.
I understand,
but he's,
you understand like how frustrating that
is.
This is a minor thing.
Someone him lying,
not lying.
Okay,
somebody,
he said,
someone told him,
I believe he's telling the truth,
but it's not true.
He could have fucking called me.
He's got my number man.
Call me.
So he didn't even bother calling me
[inaudible] about to go live from
Austin,
Texas.
I need to know did someone threaten your
family?
Stop talking about the moon landing and
big foot sturgeon.
Same Magic to fucking imagine that going
to threaten you to,
you got to stop talking about big foot
man.
I'm like,
well no,
I,
I found,
I did a show.
This is a well documented,
I've talked about it a hundred times in
the podcast.
I did a show called Joe Rogan questions,
everything and during that show,
over a period of six months,
I fucking question a lot of shit
legitimately,
but I did it with researchers.
We had the staff,
we had producers,
we went and we actually went to like
these places where these people are
claiming to see you fo's who went to
these places where people are claiming
to be able to uh,
what does that shit they do?
Remote viewing.
Remote view.
Yeah.
We talked to those guys.
Great movie.
We talked to all these people and I
found a real,
a clear thread through all of it that I
documented in my 2014 comedy central
special where I said,
here's what you don't find.
When you go looking for bigfoot black
people,
what you do find is unfuckable white
dudes,
you will more likely define big foot.
Then you are black people out looking
for big wholesale alien abductions
probably can.
It's dudes you can't get laid and they
go looking for hidden mysteries.
It need that.
This is a real big part of it.
I know.
My point is from doing that,
show it,
it's soured me off conspiracy theories.
Conspiracy theories were fun for me and
me and my,
especially Eddie Bravo mean Eddie Bravo
would get high and we'd watched
documentaries on flying rods and all
this ufo documentaries and all the
other,
the the,
the fucking
Zachariah sitch and she love it.
I love that.
I love that stuff.
But here's the thing,
I used to watch a,
a chariots of the gods all the time to
get it all falls apart under scrutiny.
It all of it,
all,
all of it.
It's fun,
but it falls apart if you're being a
serious person.
And if you really being honest about
what you actually know,
this is the problem.
It's like the saint and the parallels,
like that comparison comparing to Alex
Jones,
saying that my family was threatened.
It's the same thing.
My family was never threatened.
No one ever threatened me.
So,
but he's saying this on the radio.
Why is he saying it?
Because someone told him and he may be,
he believes it and he also thinks it's
fun to say.
It's the thing to say if you're really
into conspiracies,
but this is the problem with these
fucking conspiracies.
They say things they don't know are true
and they say,
I'm like,
they're true now.
This is fine.
If you just hold on,
it's fine if it's not an issue.
If you're talking about the Illuminati,
if you talking about your kid getting
shot,
if your kid's dead and someone says,
hey man,
this fucking Tom Smith on the radio
saying you're full of Shit.
You're a crisis actor and your kid's not
dead me and you're crying every night.
You wake up in the middle of night
crying because some fucking guy,
but you are a little bit,
I'm just visiting this right to be Alex
Jones.
I and I defend that as well
for being David.
I'll coat one time I would have David
Allen Coe do.
I played a show with David [inaudible].
This is not any,
let's get sandy hook out of this because
I'm not trying to talk about this.
Let's make some defending the right of
people to be who they are.
And I love David Alinka is music and all
that,
but I played a show with David Onco one
time and my dad always would tell me
these things about him.
You know,
he,
he really,
he liked David and everything,
but there was always kind of a little
distance of like,
there was a showman ship part of him and
they're like a good example of this,
again,
distancing from sandy hook.
But a good part of it was that when,
when David Allan Coe,
we did a show with him one time my mom
was over on the side of the stage of me.
I was opening for him.
This is many years ago before I even had
a first record out or anything.
Um,
and David Onco did a sh,
you know,
we did our song,
our set and then he played and he was
onstage and he performed a song my mom
wrote called storms never last.
So my mom's over on the side of the
stage and we were talking.
He and my mom are watching it and he's
singing it with his wife and stuff.
The next night I'm opening up for him
and he goes on stage and he goes,
last night,
Jesse culture was right in the front row
when I sang this song with my wife and
she was crying and like I'm sitting
there going,
I was here and she was not crying.
She was standing as you called it.
She was not on the front row.
Right,
right.
My mom just killed her,
wrote this song,
storms never last teasing and,
and that's his character.
That's who he is.
All I'm saying here with like,
I'm as forgiving about him lying to the
audience because that is what he's doing
at the moment.
It's his.
I could sit there and go,
you know what,
you're,
I'm going to take you in the back.
We're going to talk,
I'm going to tell this audience tomorrow
night.
He's a liar.
He's a piece of shit.
Fuck him.
I'm not going to do that because it's
David Allen Coe.
He's done.
You just sit it on the show,
which is,
I'm not much larger audience heading the
millions and millions of pieces of shit.
I'm just saying I do character,
but why would I do that to him?
Because it's like,
you know,
I just feel like,
look man,
the Times that I met Alex,
the Times I've been around him,
yeah man,
his Gig is this and he got called out
for a specific thing.
Yes,
it involves the lives of children and
everything that I understand that I'm
not,
I'm not at all sympathizing for those
family or for him versus those families.
But I'm just saying,
I just think that like at the moment
everything is so hot with this and it's,
and it's kind of exhausting and it's the
Internet is the reason for it.
And in my opinion,
because I think that like all of the
years that have come along,
the mass amount of people that have
migrated to social media,
the way that the integrated
conversations happened,
the way that that stuff ends up on the
news now,
like aol chat rooms in fucking 1998 that
shit did not end up on CNN.
People were not listening to those,
that the best thing to get,
the closest you could get to fucking tv
was to catch a Predator when you were on
that at that time.
You know?
And I feel like at this point in time,
people need,
again,
not those families there lawsuit.
That's fine.
That's their thing.
But,
but I just feel like people need to
lighten up a little bit.
In the sense of,
uh,
I just think that the social media thing
is very hazardous and I think that
people's faith in all of it,
it doesn't have to do with,
with fake news and it doesn't have to do
with Russian bots and all this shit.
I just think that like Alex Jones is a
casualty because he's always been,
what do you mean by it doesn't have to
do with fake news and Russian by,
I mean that like teachers always excuses
for all the reasons why people
understand you.
That's real,
right?
I believe that of course fake news is
real,
but
there's like,
there's,
there's an NPR document.
No,
no,
no.
I'm a radio lab podcast about Russian
troll farms.
It's fucking fascinating.
It's really interesting.
I mean,
these people show up at work and their,
their basic job is to put propaganda out
on instagram and social media and
twitter and comments.
And I agree on that stuff.
I agree.
But,
but let's,
let's get out of it.
Let me,
let me tell you an example.
Uh,
what I,
what I have seen of this,
I run a bulletin board system called
bits sunrise,
which is like old technology that used
to be modems used to dial into
Baltimore.
It systems.
You can tell net into it.
Tell net is a port port 23 is the telnet
port.
Well dvrs also share port 23.
So dvrs like to have yards like your,
your TV connected to storing your not
all,
not all.
Yeah.
Will you,
if you record a show on a weekly basis,
it is.
There is an open port.
It's not always 23 on the units,
but it's shared with,
with the telnet port.
So during the election,
during the months up to the election and
the months after the election,
I would say four months,
five months leading up five months after
on my bolt.
This kind of technical when it,
when I'm trying to explain this to,
but uh,
uh,
when you,
when you tell net into a computer you
use for mine,
you would tell them that end and it
would give you a log in you,
it has a picture this drawn and you,
you put your name and your address or
your password and you log in.
Well,
during the five months leading up to the
election and the five months afterwards,
I was getting every day,
probably all day long,
10 or 20 connections that were coming in
and they were just,
uh,
wouldn't say a Bot.
They were like,
they were scripts that were trying to
log into dvrs and trying to log in to,
um,
like Ip cameras that you can control and
everything like that.
So I was watching for,
for that about a year period.
So let me pause you here.
So you're saying that these bots,
we're trying to control dvrs and cameras
that people have on their television.
They were just testing and 90% of them
were coming for China.
10% of them are coming from maybe Russia
and other places,
but 90% China,
Korea,
because you can look at the Ip
addresses.
So what are they testing for the test?
All their flaws and they're trying to do
is they would try,
they would be looking for a Lennox
login,
which would be like um,
you know,
login again,
like if you were to tell net or ssh into
a device like that,
the first thing that would get was a
login and usually it's root is the
controller.
And so they were just trying to find,
they were just just blindly mass blindly
going to Ip addresses in trying to hack
into them route and then they try
password.
Then they try like this.
They tried that,
they tried the black,
you know,
so the Russian Bot thing,
I understand that,
but I don't think it was a coordinated
effort.
I think that like all during that whole
time I was watching my computer,
like I have,
it's kind of,
I'm getting real nerdy here,
but it's like I have these games that
like in that people play and like once
you get past the 13th,
14th,
15th node,
which essentially means like once
there's 15 people playing at the same
time,
then the game stop working.
So I would be having to deal with these
Chinese and Russia thing,
Russian and all these,
all of them just mass trying to just
break in.
And it was because of the dvrs and
because the Ip cameras,
like they were really literally trying
to hack your system to just do whatever.
I don't know what the purpose was,
but like I watched it and it was,
it was China mostly.
I mean Russia was a small amount and I
think that all those countries all the
time or have people that are constantly
trying to uh,
hack and interact with these,
uh,
with our shit.
I mean,
it's just a thing,
you know,
there's that as well.
There's that as well.
Yeah.
But I think all of there's that as well.
But there's also people that are
absolutely trying to influence
elections.
They're absolutely trying to influence
our system and that they're trying to
manipulate political parties and they're
trying to start descent.
And this is one of the things that's
really fascinating about this,
a radiolab podcast where they talk about
how these Russian troll farms literally
set up protests.
They hired people to pretend to be
Donald Trump,
and they hired people to pretend to be
hillary and put her in a cage and have
people chanting,
lock her up.
Like this is all manufactured descent
and manufactured outrage that there
they're strategically promoting.
I mean,
that's fascinating to me.
But here you've got to think,
pause for a second.
You got to think Russia is we,
you're talking about a giant place.
Okay.
So to pretend that what's happening with
these people hacking into dvrs and web
cameras is all that's happening.
So,
but you're saying what you're exposed to
that you witnessed as small example of
what happens when people are exploiting
vulnerabilities in systems.
But that doesn't mean that's the only
thing that's going on.
No,
I'm not saying that at all.
I know you're not,
but I want to clarify.
There's a lot of things that are going
on.
on because people are dealing with these
new technologies and these cases terms
and which way?
Well,
with the Russian hacking elections thing
like,
and I don't like to get political
because I don't really fuck,
you don't have to get political.
Look at it objectively looking at it
like a system.
Like look at it like this,
look at it like you have a body.
Okay.
And your body has an immune system and
your body's immune system is constantly
under threat of all sorts of different
things.
You,
you fucking touch a door knob,
you wipe your nose.
There's a lot of shit going on.
Right?
This is very similar if you just looked
at it objectively to what happens
whenever you have a server on the
Internet,
when you,
we need,
you hear about the Republican Party
getting hacked into or you know,
different people's emails getting
exploited by,
you know,
someone from outside.
That's a hacker.
What is that?
Well that's they're trying to find a way
through the system.
It's just natural thing.
If you put up a wall,
people go,
hmm,
how do I get past that wall?
You know,
if you make $34,000 a year and a guy
makes $1 million,
what does that guy know?
There's,
this is a natural thing that happens.
How is this any different?
Like I guess what I'm trying to ask
about this,
it's like when I was watching that
happen with my system,
it's like how is this any different than
what is going on for the last hundred
years?
Cause he comes.
Okay.
Because it's new because no one has been
able to get it.
I don't know.
It's new.
No one has been able to get into your
folders before.
No one's been able to get,
no,
no.
One kid sitting in Czechoslovakia who
has a computer has been able to figure
out how to turn your Webcam on and watch
it beat off.
This is a new thing,
but we didn't have a Webcam to beat off.
It doesn't matter for,
but you understand what I'm saying?
Yeah.
This is a new thing.
So because this is a new thing,
I feel like for some reason,
but it is human nature thing.
It is human nature.
But I don't understand what your point
is.
Well,
I guess what I'm asking here is,
is,
is in,
in the way of the,
I just feel like the Russian Bot thing
is,
was all of that,
I feel like the Russian bots is,
is a,
is a term for people who don't
understand computers in a way,
and they've,
they've just kind of thrown that out
there as a political device sometimes.
I think that Russia,
China,
Korea,
like every other fucking country that is
enabled in a way in which they're so far
ahead technologically was involved in
all kinds of fucking fuckery.
And there's still involved in it.
It will still do that.
During the election it was fucking a
hundred times.
Sure.
But,
uh,
you know,
I'm just,
I just,
it's hard for me,
you know,
back circling around to the Alex Jones
thing,
all of this new technology,
all of the people who are awake woke
facebook on facebook.
They know you're an angel,
you're woke on facebook.
So wake,
you know,
it's like a,
I felt bad for fucking childish Gambino
that he had a song that had stay woke
and it,
because immediately that song that that
was what an amazing song and it was a,
it was that that term became dumb
immediately.
But I,
but I just feel like,
um,
all of this that's happening,
all of this talk,
all of the him getting banned,
all of this stuff,
it's all this kind of like effect of the
world instead of being out in the world.
Everyone has,
has,
has gone to this point where it's,
you know,
these groups,
these really rich groups,
Google and facebook and twitter and all
this and everyone has,
has gone to this central point and other
lynching people,
whether or not you agree with Alex
Jones,
whether or not you like him,
whether or not I think he's being
launched in the situation right there.
So I get,
I get that there's all these people that
are doing all these different nefarious
things.
This has been going on forever and now
they're using new systems to do that.
They using the internet and all these
open pipes and these connections that
they can make trick is that the public
is there.
They've gotten them to go to this a one
arena.
That is my problem with it.
Is it like as much of a nerd and a
technology person?
I am.
I like,
I hate that people have instead of
really,
I mean I'm sure they have their own
lives but like the fact that we have
become so centralized to these small
groups of Internet companies like social
media and things and then now look,
it's on both sides man.
I mean Alex Jones is getting lynched.
Harvey Weinstein,
whatever.
I know he's,
he's a very different things,
but every,
everyone is a very,
very,
very different than not defending him.
But I understand how you made this
behavior,
but the connection is the fast
connection as people were just attack
the findings.
The minute it look,
those people could have suits against
Harvey Weinstein,
Stein Steen,
and we can know about it.
Of course we knew about it because the
Wall Street Journal or what,
whoever,
or New York Times who were in that thing
was a new yorker.
Yeah.
The new,
yeah.
But
I guess my point is,
is,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I'm sure this is an unpopular opinion,
but I just feel like that the
centralization of society into social
media is resulting in a lot of things
that are very ugly.
And I think that the Russian Bot thing,
the Chinese hackers thing,
the Alex Jones issue,
the me too movement,
all that stuff,
which I,
I'm,
I'm behind all the people that,
that were hurt.
I'm not,
I'm behind the sandy hooks people on
behind the people who had the bad
experiences in Hollywood.
All that.
What are you proposing?
What are you saying?
I'm just saying that I think that,
that it's unhealthy.
I think that social media thing has
become too centralized.
There needs to be decentralized,
uh,
sort of centralized because there's all
your kids in groups.
They are instagram.
I mean,
it's 100% centralized.
it's owned by a group,
several groups.
It's several,
uh,
you know,
everyone's kind of going to Mcdonald's
to have these conversations as opposed
to it being something that is a little
more healthy.
I just find,
I just think that that people,
I think Alex Jones should have always
been able to be crazy in his world.
And he was always nice to me.
And you,
you said he's your friend.
Like,
you know what the problem with Alex's,
he needs someone sitting right next to
them.
Someone like me,
someone who when he talks and he said
something crazy,
go wait a minute.
Wait,
how do you know that?
And he goes,
well we have the documents will show me
the documents.
Well the documents don't say that.
Well you know,
the problem is,
or they are definitely trying to
influence.
And he'd go,
yeah,
they probably are.
But if you leave them alone,
if you leave them alone and just let
them rant.
By the way,
he's doing six hours,
eight hours of radio a fucking day.
And he's definitely likes to drink.
So he's doing six hours of radio a day.
At least three of them are drunk and
he's fucking fill in time and screaming
and no one can say anything to him.
And he's the fucking man over there.
That's also part of the problem.
He's got a bunch of these other people
that are around them all the time and
there conspiracy theories as well.
But there are 28 and you know,
and then you know,
they're hanging out with Alex Jones and
it goes on rants and no one interrupts
them.
It's abroad argument with all of it
because I agree.
But he was always,
he was always transmitting.
He was always like,
Hey,
show me where the Satanists are going to
worship it took to sacrifice children.
That's fine.
But I get it.
I think what happened is now the idea is
that he's influencing people
politically.
Like the whole,
you know the whole uh,
Podesta pizza gate,
that all that stuff was scared the shit
out of people when that guy showed up at
that pizza place and fire off around and
you know,
and then they want up arrest them and
they really thought there was a dungeon
in the basement where again,
kids centralizing in social media is the
cause for a lot of these reactions.
Is that centralizing and social media or
is that people exciting people to go and
take action against something that may
or may not even be real?
If you are you allowed to yell out fire
in a crowded theater,
right.
This is what ultimately the problem,
right?
It's not whether or not he believes in
Bohemian Grove,
which is real and be proved it on video
back when they had vhs tapes and I
watched it.
I mean I've known Alex since 99 or 98 I
think maybe I've known for a long ass
time and that this is a very big
difference between then and what's
happening now is as far as the reach and
influence and I think people are sort of
panicking about reach and influence and
what it means and how to mitigate it,
how to change people,
how to stop people from going into pizza
places and shooting them up because they
think that something that they heard
online is true.
There's a lot of stuff that people hear
online that isn't just not true.
You know,
the lizards underground or the fucking
earth land flat and there's a lot of
stuff that's just nonsense.
So it's,
it's hard to separate.
Here's what I think.
I think we are going through an
adolescent stage as a,
as a being,
as an evolving being.
And I think our bodies and our minds and
our consciousness are becoming
synchronized with technology.
And along the way,
like right now we are in this chaotic
screaming,
sweating,
crying,
pissing shitting,
state of chaos.
And we are looking to figure out how to
stop the bleeding.
We're looking to shove thumbs into
dykes,
dykes meaning like dams and we're
looking to try to figure out a way to
stop the bleeding.
We're trying to put patches and bandaids
on things.
We're trying to manage the chaos.
We're trying to figure out what,
and this is a stage that we're going
through because this,
hold on a second.
This is a new thing.
This is a new thing for human beings.
The ability to communicate widespread
over millions and millions of people
instantaneously is a new thing.
So people have say that never had say
before,
they have influenced it,
never had an influence before.
They have their ability to contribute
and they might not have thought these
things through and these things catch
fire and they run through dry forest
like a goddamn tornado of,
of,
of flames that you see on CNN when the
Mendocino fire up in northern
California,
this is,
this is what happens with ideas because
there's no way to contain them and they
don't know what's right or what's wrong.
I think that what we're going through
from the period of 1994 the period of
2018 is like a crazy fire in the middle
of a hurricane.
It's like everything is nuts and no one
knows how to stop it and no one knows
what to do and what do we do?
We get together and shelters and we
fucking give people water and we tried
to stop the fire and take away
everyone's lighters and that's what
we're doing right now.
We're trying to take away lighters.
We trying to stop people who start fires
and this is what's happening with Alex
and it's not that Alex is a bad guy,
is that he has,
he's by himself eras.
It's irresponsible to say that you know,
for sure a fact that these parents from
sandy hook or crisis actors and their
kids never died.
It's irresponsible.
And he didn't think it was irresponsible
when he was doing
it because he's probably caught up in
what he does and he's caught up in the
wave of ad libbing just like you and I
are ad living.
We didn't even talk about what the fuck
we're going to talk about.
Right.
Turned on and where we had a couple of
drinks.
You're,
what you're saying there is very red.
I don't mean to cut you off.
It's okay,
but,
but what you're saying there is very
smart because to me,
uh,
you know,
it is,
it's,
you're right.
He,
he has always been doing this and it
just point in time his reach has grown,
right.
And he's now there's a wind behind him.
He used to be it.
Oh,
in Seattle.
It was raining every day and he had a
little patch of dry newspaper,
like that shit on fire and everybody go,
ah,
Alex is crazy.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I think,
I think what I'm trying to articulate,
and I'm not doing as well as I wanted
to,
but I think what my problem is,
is the synchronization of consciousness
is what I'm not into.
I think that I think,
you know,
just like you have a Rut of people who
believe that,
uh,
you know,
they now believe that the sandy hook
thing is fake and they're calling the
families because of this conversation.
This is where that lawsuit is really
coming from because the other people,
but then you also have another side of
it.
And it could be,
as you know,
back in the day when they said that Paul
Mccartney was dead,
but they got harassed,
but it was on such a small level because
there was no way to just email Paul
Mccartney and,
or email and say,
you're not the real public mccartney.
You're fucking dead.
Not just that.
There was no way to exchange these ideas
amongst people real time on facebook all
day long,
which is the centralization that creates
these rivers and in these ruts that
people who don't know what to do and
they fall into one rut or another and
they kind of become this,
this,
this kind of streamline thing.
So I think the way you just described it
as is very,
um,
articulate essentially thing.
Matt is a new thing when we are in a
really exciting time.
But why,
why I say that?
Because they used to say that about the
printing press.
They used to worry about that with the
written word.
They used to worry about that with
everything.
The distribution of information is not,
it's not whether or not it's healthy,
it's just a part of what the,
this being does with this being does is
constantly search for innovation and
novelty.
That's what,
that's what the human being does.
But like I guess,
I guess yes,
but it was looking at your phone over
there,
man,
you got to fucking iphone.
Don't you think you could go to the
people making an iphones and go,
hey bro,
we're good.
Yeah.
Yes.
Is it,
and this is stop.
You can stop.
It's not,
we're not good.
These mother fuckers are ready to come
out with the iphone 11 then like the guy
you're not going to stop been at the web
was invented hyperlinks.
And the idea was that if someone went to
hog dude,
this is just,
oh I'm in,
I'm in.
So like the guy invented the web stolen
the time and I should know his name.
Gore mother fucker hover,
right.
It was funny.
Think you lie.
So this cat,
this cat a,
all he wanted to do was make it
basically we're like medical documents
where you would,
where you would say like,
you know this guy had a brain transplant
and then brain transplant will be
underlined and you clicked on that and
it would take you to a link that
explained brain transplants and that
would be worldwide.
So the Internet is decentralized and the
web is decentralized to some degree.
Okay.
Now Google coming in with search
engines,
like that's focusing points.
What scares me is those people being
like facebook being the avenue in
whichever it be talks like I,
I should scare you is a weed I just
handed you holy Shit.
I took two hits and I'm not even here
anymore.
I'm an anti yet I am very high.
That's a blunt.
That's legit.
It took two hits.
I liked a little bit louder.
I'll fuck around here in California Sun.
But you know what I mean?
Like I just have a problem with the
centralization of the companies owning
the avenues in which get taught.
I right,
I'm right.
I'm right with you on that.
I think we need more youtube.
I think we need more venues for people
to distribute,
distribute information.
But I also think we need more love,
more compassion.
There's so much hate and anger towards
each other.
I feel like I'm going to get dark nailed
here on this because I'm not,
I am not.
It's part of the nervousness about doing
a live show right after Bush while you
were talking.
I would say,
um,
well,
I mean I'm not,
I'm very nervous right now.
I have a fucking drink.
But,
but I would say five.
It's,
I'm very nervous.
I would say that.
Um,
oh,
this is one of those ones were there.
That's,
yeah,
it's tobacco,
tobacco and some shit that was grown on
Mars.
You know,
Armstrong groups we man,
see I again,
again,
it was just like there was a point when
you're trying to make sense right now.
This is part of the problem,
right?
I know.
This is why I wanted us to get here and
we're getting,
we're getting super serious about topics
that are very,
that mean a lot to people and we don't
really know enough about it.
I just,
I just feel like,
I just wish that there weren't,
like,
again,
I just,
I feel like there's reps that have
people have to fall in to communicate
and there and there are ruts that are
owned by these companies that,
that are very fucking rich and varied.
Here's the thing too.
These companies didn't see this.
Like I'm libertarian,
I'm not either way.
And just in the sense I'm not really
that,
I don't even fucking know what that is.
All I know is I don't believe in
trusting anybody who,
who says,
Hey,
I'll take care of you.
Come this way.
Just don't worry about a thing.
And they're the ones making all the
money.
And it's like,
that's how the Internet has become.
It used to be a wild west of
information.
Emails are fucking information that is,
that's me communicating with you and no
one else seeing it.
That's beautiful.
And I think the idea of twitter and
facebook and all that,
it's fantastic when it first started,
but at the this point in time,
it's gotten so big,
if it doesn't break up into something
where people figure out that they are in
control of the Internet,
not these other people.
That's what it bothers me.
Okay.
So what bothers you?
Is it someone comes along and says the
people aren't in control of the
Internet,
so it's not like a free market.
The free,
hold on,
sorry.
It was a free market.
It's a free market.
A guy like Alex Jones,
you'd say this guy is preposterous.
I'm not listening to him anymore.
When it's not a free market is when
youtube collapse.
Well,
I dunno if they collaborate.
If they just all agree.
I don't know if they all agree,
but they just all decide everyone's
going to take them off.
Facebook's gonna suspend him for 30
days.
Twitter's going to suspend it for a
period of time.
Youtube is going to remove them.
All these people are going to take vimeo
jumped on ship and they pulled them off
too.
So this,
this becomes an issue like what is it
that causes you to get removed?
What is it and should we be really clear
on that or is this just a whim because
this is a really important thing.
If we really are fucking with free
speech we have to be very careful on
what we decide.
Is is a valid reason to pull people off
of our airways?
Because if you have stuff on your
airways that's far more vile and you let
that stay up because it doesn't have the
same reach,
like what is your criteria?
It doesn't have the same influence.
It doesn't have the same political ties
to it.
Like,
what is the reason why you're pulling
one thing off and not another thing?
Is it because of the popularity issue?
Have you searched your trillions of
fucking hours of footage for offensive
speech,
content,
ideas,
disinformation,
what have you,
what have you really done to mitigate
this issue or are you acting on this
because it's a social hotspot issue
right now,
which it most certainly is and most
certainly should be.
I really think that Alex needs a guy
right next to him.
He really like,
I understand this and I did a show
together and Howard Stern,
man,
no,
not the same comparison.
I guess Howard's but listen man,
let's do him every day.
But sometimes I want to be like,
dude,
are you kidding me?
But that's also part of his charm,
part of his charm and she creates
descent in arguments and you want to get
mad and you want to either he's
opinionated well,
but how it's turns very responsible.
He's a different guy.
It's not,
it's not the same thing.
I'm not trying to compare Alex to him.
I'm just saying that sometimes I feel
the same way about it.
About him and it had to feel that way
about us right now.
This is quit cutting fucking Giorgio
moroder tribute records and do a country
record.
You know,
and I do a country record right now and
they're like,
oh,
it's kind of corny.
No.
Uh,
now I got a record coming by the way.
I'm sure you do,
Dude.
I told you I wake up the Triscuit deca
phobia every morning.
In fact,
that's the Stephen King.
I will,
uh,
I'm going to fucking set it so people
know I'm not bullshitting.
I'm going to set my alarm.
What time's it right now?
It's two oh five.
I'm going to set my alarm for two oh
five two oh five perfect.
Five triscuit,
decorative phobia.
You know,
I also just,
just along with what you're saying is
it's like,
you know,
Oh,
it is two oh five guy.
It has to be free.
Hold the whole sentence.
No,
it's two.
Oh.
Oh Oh you're a cathode ray light or
clock is things bullshit.
Oh,
it just turned two oh six.
Come on pitch.
Why don't you go on?
Hmm.
Try it.
Thinks I'm retarded.
Let's go with 2:08 PM that's fact.
That's why we give ourselves a little
buffer.
No,
I just feel like,
you know,
and I fucking,
this topic could be,
we know we're not,
we're not qualified to have this
conversation,
but no one is.
Yeah.
So it's just,
as long as we're honest about how we
feel about things.
Look,
I didn't go,
oh you guys are off.
You guys are off.
They were a little off.
I believe.
I believe in protecting children's
innocence in a certain way that I,
I agree with youtube not allowing porn
and stuff like that,
you know,
because like my kids look at youtube all
the time,
but what about twitter,
twitter or loss?
A certain amount of porn.
Sometimes we flipping through my time,
my phone down,
I gotta go Yo Kendra la slow at town.
Yeah.
Nice call out.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
it may as well have like,
I believe if Isis,
if Alex Jones and if the unboxing of the
Lolz can exist,
what does that mean?
Like oils,
my daughter,
these toys,
lls,
shopkins and things like that where they
show videos of them are the slime videos
of doing this,
like youtube and those kinds of things.
I just think that there is a certain
level of like,
just ignore it.
If you don't like it.
Well it's not your thing.
The lawsuit thing.
Totally.
That's out of this context a little bit.
He went too far with that big difference
between something that you might find
gross and something that changes
culture.
I think what they're worried about is,
do you remember when Jim Acosta did
that?
Uh,
he went to that trump rally and they
went crazy on him.
Do you remember that shit?
I don't know.
Is it a recent thing?
Weeks ago?
This is CNN anchor who is reasonably
self righteous,
but he's in a difficult situation.
He's,
he has to challenge the president of the
United States who is also a famous
celebrity billionaire guy.
What's his name on buildings?
I mean this literally is Rosebud.
This is,
this is the tale of citizen Kane.
I mean,
this is someone with an ungodly power
and influence and this gym,
and I'm not standing up for Jim Acosta.
I'm just going to say,
just put yourself in that guy's
position.
What a crazy spot.
You're yelling out.
Questions at the president of United
States who also happens to be Donald
Trump.
You think like you're on acid the world.
The world has gone into a vortex of
crazy and you're the guy by some fucking
freak of chance,
whether you're Jim Acosta or don lemon
or,
or fill in the blank.
Everyone up,
it went off.
You heard it,
he hit the button.
I accidentally hit the button to do this
correctly,
but it mean if you're one of those
fucking people,
I'm going to hold this picture.
It was the weed.
Oh Shit.
I've got to that off
for a few seconds ago.
If you're one of those fucking people
and that's your job,
and we expect them to handle that.
That's probably like being beyonce and
the rock on steroids,
you know?
But,
but in a negative way,
it wouldn't be those two because those
are like very beloved celebrities.
Like very few people are as beloved as
the rock or beyonce.
They're pretty much universally beloved,
the person uniquely so they're so loved
and so deserving of that love.
Uh,
but if you're a guy like who's a like a
real like Takashi six,
nine,
that kid like you imagine the hate that
guy gets all day.
Now imagine what's that?
He said six.
He's a rapper listening
every morning I wake up,
see my friend.
I hope this doesn't get off pulled off
of youtube.
Alex,
can we do that whole thing?
Shooter Jennings Bitch recognize.
Oh you brought an album delivered.
We can sign off.
Oh beautiful.
I love it.
Thanks Adam.
You got some bad ass.
It's
fucking music.
Thanks.
You really do.
I love your music and you know,
one of the things I love about your
music is like,
um,
it's all different man.
You got some straight up country,
put the o back in country.
You got to that,
you've got that,
that whole album man.
This is like a bad ass country album,
you know.
But like with this twist,
like a respectful country album that
also has a lot of like modern wickedness
to it.
You know,
I appreciate that was the point.
Like when we were,
when we were doing the first record,
it was me and Ted Wrestle camp.
He still plays with me and Leroy pal who
doesn't play with me anymore,
but he played on that record.
He played guitar.
Brian Kaylin was a drummer.
We started doing our shit.
Like our idea was we were living here,
you know,
I just,
I had 2003 we started recording the
first record and I had met her three
years ago and we were like,
our whole thing was like,
we like rock music because it sounds
cool.
And we like Dylan and we like,
you know,
even,
I wasn't even smart enough to like Dylan
then we were like into fucking,
you know,
Bowie and I was,
I can't came for the nine inch nails
side get it.
That's how I got into music.
We kind of talked about that near the
show.
But,
uh,
like by that time the idea was like,
can we make country music?
We like the old stuff but have it sound
cool and why can't we bring in like the
stuff that raw that's cool about rock
and why can't you go psychedelic and why
can't you kind of push the limits that
way.
And we were just dumb and trying to do
it that way.
And Dave Cobb,
who produced this record,
we met,
we met that back then and he produced
the first record and he was the same
way.
We were like more Beatles stones,
Bowie kids musically in the,
in the amount of records we listened to,
you know,
obsessed over pink floyd and stuff,
then we were a country.
So we were kind of trying to blend those
two back then.
I,
you know,
but we were just,
just trying and starting and doing weird
shit.
And then after a while just evolving.
Um,
yeah,
but the album would be totally
different.
Like you don't give a fuck dude.
It's about the guy who invested in apple
in the eighties
you just,
you just do your music,
man,
you do your music and whatever you're
into right now is like what you do.
It's really interesting,
like,
oh,
I appreciate that.
And that,
I mean,
I've listened to,
I've listened to every one of your cds
and there's only a few of them that are
even similar,
you know,
similar to each other.
They're all,
they're all,
all your albums,
I guess you can say albums again.
These two cause became cd for awhile.
But who the fuck gets a CD old man.
And then it's like,
I can't say online playlist.
You newest online playlist.
They're like,
what do I say about your newest stems?
Our playlist man.
Audio release.
Yeah man.
Uh,
no.
You know what's black ribbons happen
man?
I did the first record and that was kind
of my take on country and our take as a
band and Dave cobb and then,
but before that record came out,
we started recording the second record
and I was like,
the first song I wrote was a song
electric Rodeo.
And we,
and I was like,
I wanted to go heavy.
I wanted to like,
just really show up and like do this
kind of hard rocky sounding.
And what I mean by that is like,
you know,
fucking we're into Zeplin and shit,
like nineties music.
It was like,
uh,
you know,
seventies ship.
But it was like hard rock,
crazy effects.
Immigrants saw kind of going crazy.
But with the song,
the country songs there.
And I always felt if electric rodeo got
considered a country record when it came
out and charted than I felt we,
like we had done our thing.
But it did come out and it did chart.
But once we came out with that,
we had universal who had been behind us
and they had basically been the,
the people that worked at universal had
been kind of in my opinion and their
opinion duped because Tony Brown and Tim
to Blah,
who believed in me and we had done this
record without a deal and I sent it to
Tony Brown cause I knew I just as a kid
had met him and him and my dad had done
business and I liked him and there was,
he had made me feel like he liked me.
So I sent him this record after me and
the band.
And Dave did the record and uh,
they believed in me and they signed it
and he kind of like remixed our first
song so they would play it on radio.
And Tony was a big producer,
still is.
I mean he produced the first bunch Steve
Earle records and he played piano for
Elvis.
Like he and he was our label heads,
so he kinda remixed it.
So we get on radio.
So I'm thinking they like me cause we
have like kind of a 20 number 24 yet.
So I'm like,
I'm going to hit him with some good shit
now.
And then I hit him with what I thought
was a good shit and they said,
this is
not what we signed up for.
We are out,
you're out.
And I never got played on radio again.
So,
you know,
that's all stuff that's on them,
dude.
I know.
It's the reason why your music is so
well.
It's just good.
I mean I like,
I like a lot of great music and your
music is great,
but it's also that you,
you're clearly coming at this from an
artist perspective.
You're not a marketing genius by any
stretch of the imagination,
right?
Your Dad's fucking waylon jennings dude.
I mean you have the end of all ends.
You're dad is like a super legend,
you know?
I mean these are super,
super legend,
but you choose to legitimately carve
your own path in this the wildest of
ways.
It's really interesting how you do that
and I think that thoughtfulness that
allows you to be free like that is also
what allows you to explore these like
complex issues like censorship or bit
coin or any of these things that are
like,
whoa,
this is like,
this is some heavy stuff.
Like you've,
you're,
you have a you of a curious approach to
these things and in a,
in a an ability to express who you
really are,
right?
Which is what,
what comes out in your music.
It's not like your image,
you're just doing what you really feel
when you're writing it.
That I think that's a,
that's a big part of a community that's
a big part of being a person.
Like let some person uniquely be
themselves.
And I think there's,
this is one of the real issue with
social media as people are so terrified
of expressing themselves because they're
terrified of the hate they get back.
But then they get addicted to attacking
other people that are failing or other
people that are making mistakes.
And that I get,
I think this again goes with this whole
fucking chaos thing that we're talking
about before.
I mean I think we're in the middle of a
storm right now and I think that your,
your take on Alex Jones and Bill Maher's
take on Alex Jones and what we're saying
here about them,
it doesn't,
it like it doesn't in any way negate
arguments that you shouldn't say some of
the things he's saying we agree with
you.
But we also say human beings,
we have to figure this out together.
And if you start conflict and one great
way to start conflict is to ban and to
take people down popio call people in
Nazi that aren't really a Nazi,
like decide that someone's an outright
white supremacists when they're really
not at all.
There are liberal and a Democrat and you
know they are,
you're saying crazy things you could to
try to demonize people and slot them
into groups.
We have to reject that with every fiber
of our being because this is tyranny.
This is the type of group tyranny that
although it's not connected to a network
like the fucking,
you know,
the KKK or the Democrats or the
Republicans,
it's still this chaotic group.
Think thing that happens.
What we decided to go after people and
stop being compassionate,
stop being just a human being who
recognizes that other human beings are
flawed and they make mistakes and they
do stupid shit,
but as soon as you oppose them so
vehemently for something that really
should be treated with curiosity and
compassion and maybe a little bit of
understanding and mockery instead of
that there's this anger and this vitriol
that we just have to put a curb on
shitty thinking.
I agree.
It's kind of like new Roman Colosseum,
social media,
and it is in a way,
but it's also,
it's fighting each court,
cheering it on.
The court of public discourse is massive
now.
It just opened up a gate.
It was a little trickle.
It was like that fucking border patrol
station in Mexico.
It's hard to get in the country,
Bro.
If you want to do,
be that guy or risks his life in the
middle of August and take your family
through the fucking desert with a couple
of jugs of water and you're going to
walk and hope you find a job.
You know?
That's what it used to be like,
hey,
this is like is the walls came down and
they changed the law and everybody said,
go ahead in.
And everybody's in Wa and the end and
down to people going down to up and
down.
Just opening it up.
It's getting crazy.
See,
this is what everybody's afraid of and
this is what,
this is what's happening right now with
information.
This is what's happening for the very
first time ever,
but between this period of 1994 and 2018
it's been this inevitable change in the
way people are able to express
information and who gets to express
information.
You know,
they'll question the legitimacy of
someone who becomes famous to the
Internet but not famous through NBC.
He made it.
He's on NBC.
Meanwhile,
this guy is just talking to his Webcam.
He has 30 times as many people paying
attention to him.
Why is he wrong?
Why is the incorrect?
Because he didn't go through your
established channels that have existed
with WHO's your gatekeepers?
Oh guys like Harvey Weinstein.
Where your gatekeepers bitch,
get the fuck outta here.
You don't get to dictate what's
interesting or what's creative or what
sounds good.
What kind of music people like.
It used to be that if you like rock,
you didn't like country when I was a
kid.
You are a loser if you like kiss,
right dude,
you,
you would get like categorize.
I had to hide some music that I liked
and kiss was one of them.
I told,
I told Paul,
Stanley didn't seem to appreciate that.
I told Gene Simmons ones too.
I was like,
dude,
I'm sorry.
But it was true.
I was loyal back when it was uncool to
like kiss and then it turned around and
became super lawyer of Eddie Bravo has
to save story.
We both were like embarrassed to be
kissed fans,
but meanwhile,
now I fucking love kiss.
I love kiss,
but I,
you know,
I also,
I also love Willie Nelson.
You know,
I love listening to all kinds of
different shit.
It doesn't connect mutually exclusive.
Like for me,
I didn't,
I grew up with my dad and had country
came along.
Like once I started living life and I
started appreciating the songs,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
like when you started actually kind of
understanding the words and all that,
and like you,
it just,
it hits you like,
Oh shit,
this,
this shit is like the heavy shit.
It's like there's some deep,
deep fucking emotions to country songs.
I mean,
Johnny Cash just as lyrics alone,
like some of his songs are fucking
phenomenal men.
Yeah.
They're phenomenal.
You know,
you know what one always blows me away
on
cash is the man in black still to this
day,
the lines like uh,
you know the uh,
what is it to the thousands that died
thinking that the Lord we're on their
side and then Harris to the hundreds of
the are tens of thousands that died
thinking that we were all on their side
like that verse and everything.
I was looking at it,
I forgot to look it up.
Hey,
would you mind looking up who wrote the
man in black?
Sorry to ask you that.
But I've been dying to know that because
I wanted to know if Shel Silverstein was
involved or if it was just Johnny Cash
at wrote it.
But that's such a beautiful song,
dude.
How about um,
well folsom prison blues.
All right,
of course.
Fantastic.
But how about God's going to cut you
down?
Oh,
that's miss.
These favorite,
that's a song.
I love that song.
That's a song they like chills you to
your bone.
Yeah.
Cause he was an old,
old man.
We did three songs like the,
Oh my God,
that's,
it.
Has that right?
The big kind of like,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
That's good.
That one.
And the man comes around.
Those two were really spoken to her.
Oh yeah.
Riddick that Shel Silverstein.
That's why I was wondering.
Yeah.
Shell wrote that Shell's like the
forgot.
He's the guy that brought like the New
York sense of humor and,
and really cultured writing style,
like the kind of hunters Thompson world.
He's the link between that and country
music for sure.
Shel Silverstein,
I got to be around him a couple times
when I was young.
He wrote it.
He though cash wrote the signature song
man in black.
That's good.
Social conscience behind his wardrobe
choices.
Just so we're reminded of the ones who
are held back.
In fact,
he took to black simply because it was
easier to keep clean on long tours.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Early in his career,
a fellow acts teased him about it,
calling him the undertaker.
Oh Shit.
He was the undertaker for the undertaker
was the undertaker.
Yeah.
These lyrics could really,
I mean,
there this time right now,
seriously.
He was a monster man.
Johnny Cash some monster.
Yeah,
he was cool as fuck.
He's a monster.
Just had a,
uh,
he just had this energy about him.
Are those like colace zero [inaudible]
that's a,
it's a,
um,
I like doctor Stevie,
a flavored beverage so it doesn't have
any calories.
It's free guilt,
free mouth,
pleasure,
mouth,
pleasure.
Um,
he had a,
he had songs that were,
there's so many of them that were just,
if you think about the time that he was
riding them and to come up through the
son scene and Elvis and all that,
that was a weird thing.
He came in through Memphis.
Yeah.
He's a beast man.
No question.
And it seemed like he kind of died on
his own terms.
He died like a man.
He died after June died.
It was like right after June died.
That was also the way he was handling it
too,
you know?
Yeah.
I wouldn't do that.
Nine inch nails song.
Yeah.
Hurt.
That was awesome.
That was intense.
Intense.
How I see it.
You see if you give us and the
mushrooms,
the first time I saw that video,
I was in my room,
my old here in La and the star gun
house,
that was the pink house over
by the Tom Cat Theater on Santa Monica
Boulevard.
You know what I'm talking about?
And,
and uh,
no Harris Nude,
the place where you can go in there.
Oh,
I heard where's it and take pictures of
women.
It's Santa Monica and Gardner.
Anyway,
this little pink house we had over there
and uh,
I was watching that video on mushrooms
and I was like,
fucking Goddamn,
like,
let me see this.
You find it.
Find the year 2000.
When did he,
when did Johnny die?
I think 2005 or three.
No,
it was like three of those.
And I was living in this apartment on
beverly by the Beverly Center and it was
like a,
I remember that when that happened.
Say three,
Jamie.
Yeah.
Um,
I saw him there.
I got to be random a lot when I was on
the road when I was like,
I'm the first high women record came
out.
I was F six,
five and we all went on the road.
And so like Willie's daughters,
amy and Paula,
we're out and no,
actually maybe they were out.
I think there are the cost drivers in a,
they had the Christian and said their
family and then we went again for high
women too.
But the one,
we were like five year olds.
Uh,
I wish we could play music on this show.
Oh,
play the highway man song.
Oh Man.
Johnny [inaudible] that man a star ship.
I flew with damn space bar vide and
what?
I rushed to the other side,
man.
Oh man,
that was,
that was a great fucking album.
It was a great song.
I have those guys all together.
Yeah,
it was cool to shit snellman produced
that record.
It was,
it was phenomenal shit.
I fly a star ship that's Jimmy Webb
wrote that,
who wrote,
you know,
by the time I get to phoenix a
Galveston,
he wrote a macarthur park,
but he wrote all that motherfucker of a
songwriter and that sounds kind of about
reincarnation.
It's like the,
his original songs,
but one person who lived through these
different lives and then he ends up at
simple drop or rain.
Yeah,
Star ship and he was a highway man.
Fuck.
It's amazing.
That's what we're scared.
We're scared of being a single drop of
rain again.
I had scared.
It'd be so much fun.
I don't know dude.
I'm having a good time.
I know it wouldn't be easy just to fall
for five seconds for sure.
For sure.
Absolutely.
And under the next forever.
How about that?
I bought for billions of years.
How about you go back to me in a single
cell organism,
you start from scratch,
go through and you're like,
no way you did it.
It doesn't matter what matters is the
moment.
And that's an impossible concept to
grasp for people who collect stamps and
a bunch of shit.
Your whole it up in your house because
you're trying to put like some sort of
rigidity to this.
Uh,
if it theory of world that we live in,
you try to put some structure to this
and it doesn't,
he forgets to enjoy it and I
think that is part of the point or
earlier too is it's just like,
man,
everybody,
it gets wrapped up.
You said you were talking about when you
were just afterwards,
but you were talking about it.
Everybody gets sucked up into a,
all these different,
you know,
fucking confrontations all the time and
it's like,
and it takes all of your attention.
Like I think the reason that alums
aren't listened to like they used to be
because we used to have so much time,
man,
he used to sit in your room and that's
all you had.
And now there's this constant focus.
It's like there's a way,
and I think the only answer is there's
going to have to be some established
decentralization of the Internet,
the returns it to the form in which all
can exist digitally as they do
physically,
just like we do now.
And we're going to have to figure it out
as this design.
It's coming,
dude.
I don't think anyone's going to be able
to stop it.
No.
Reg,
one of the things that's interesting is
that the people at the very top of the
heap,
um,
we always thought were the proponents of
free speech.
We,
we always thought that the,
the repressive people where the right
wing conservative people that wanted to
stop progress and stop nudity and people
smoking pot and you know,
and Tipper Gore wants a bad rap music.
I remember all that.
That's what we always thought.
It's actually Tipper Gore was Democrats.
That's a very bad analogy.
Tipper Gore was Al Gore's wife Tipper
Gore put this,
but she had to speak.
She had the stickers.
Stickers.
Yeah.
Explicitly or not some fucking old
school ice tea and blew her wig.
But we always that that's a bad example
because she wasn't democratic it sample,
but it is an example of like forget
about Democrats or Republicans.
It's basically people in power trying to
control other folks.
This would be this,
this,
this has been going on forever,
right.
It's just what people do.
But we always thought of it as being the
conservative ones that were like the
most,
the the most into suppression of free
speech,
you know,
stop people you're swearing stopped the
knew that he stopped the pornography.
It was always thought of as being a
conservative thing.
But I would argue like today it's almost
like your behavior is more restricted on
the left than it is even on the right.
The right is seemed to be more relaxed
in terms of like what they're willing to
let people do.
But the left is like putting up all
these boundaries for like what people
can and can't say doing.
Don't do,
like Tom sent me this,
a Thompson,
Laura sent me this um,
photograph of a,
some sort of a sketch comedy group where
they were trying to figure out what you
can and can't do today and like what,
what is okay to do in a sketch?
And it was a lot of it was about gay
people and Trans People.
And can you be a Wa a straight CIS man
playing a trans person,
all caps?
Absolutely not.
Can you be assist purse or can you be a
trans person playing a CIS person?
Yes.
All caps.
You could do whatever you want.
If you're a trans person who's a woman,
you can play
a man and that's totally cool.
But if you're a shooter jennings and you
go,
you know what man,
I just think it would be cool.
Do a movie where I play a chick.
No chance buddy.
You're not allowed to make believe in
that way.
You can't make believe in a certain way.
They're basically saying your,
your thoughts are not allowed to go down
these roads.
There is no way you could manage this
respectfully and with with enough
people who are crazy.
But this is my point.
These people exist and they're on the
left now.
They're like super inclusive,
you know,
super worried about diversity,
super worried about,
you know,
people of color and there's all these
like gain weird words thrown around game
words.
I wish George Carlin was alive.
He would have a heart attack.
No,
I just want to tell him again.
You'd bring them back to life.
Tell him again with a hard day.
He would say what's similar to what
you're saying,
what I'm saying?
I think,
but probably better.
He would just tell he'd be so,
yeah.
I just want to know.
I guess it would die to know what he
would say.
This is,
I mean to fucking,
to use the title of my tour.
These are strange times,
legitimately strange times stranger than
we've ever experienced before as a human
race.
I think.
Yeah.
Oh,
I think so.
I think we're on the,
uh,
beginning of it.
That's the fucked up thing is I think
that like the Cha,
the Internet is the thing,
the Lynch pin that change society in
such a way,
like you said,
the adolescent phase is what dorm do
these dorm of fame.
It's a God damn hailstorm.
You ever seen those hail storms when
they hit those Ohio backyards and fuck
up the pool and everybody's in Scott
screaming and you're hearing the house,
like it's getting attacked by rocks.
That's what it is.
It's one of those hail storms of
information,
you know?
Yeah,
man,
there's never been anything like it.
It's good.
That's good.
But we just gotta be nice to each other.
We're all together in this thing
together.
That's the thing too,
man.
And people are nice.
Other people,
a nice back.
This is the thing.
We've got to realize that if you're
nice,
other people would be nice to,
we've got gotta be nice to each other
and that includes online,
you know,
and,
and then we've got to be nice about all
the other things in the world.
There's just so much that has to be
thought of it.
Someone has to be so much that it has to
be thought of.
Not with this idea that you're going to
live forever because a lot of like the
way we behave,
it's almost like we think we're going to
live forever instead of having the short
trip where you're just like kind of be
like,
is friendly with people pot and this is
also something that should be projected.
Right.
I should projected you should project
that.
We should all get that idea out there so
that we all agree like,
yeah,
yeah.
It was just fucking,
we could do this.
Like even competition.
It doesn't have to be that kind of
conflict.
Even if your neighboring businesses,
you can be friends and everybody will do
well together.
There's a lot of people,
man,
this is not a time we have to control
everything and everyone and nor should
you want to.
It's like a big giant summer camp like
life is just one piece of it.
That's a good way to describe it,
dude,
and they have their own summer camp
that's going to happen,
you know,
or are on their way at the beginning of,
yeah,
these counselors ain't controlling
shit.
People are finger banging each other out
houses,
so it gives gay,
right.
You can't let a bunch of 14 year olds
run around the forums together.
Fuck every four years.
The head counselor changes some guy.
It's like last time I was like,
Oh,
we love that guy and this guy.
It's like,
no,
nobody from the other neighbor camps are
coming in.
You're like,
okay.
We vaguely knew when I was in boy
scouts,
we vaguely knew that there was a
potential that one of these camp
counselors might molest you.
Like people knew.
You don't know about him with them.
No one ever did.
But there was that thought when we were
like,
I guess I was 13 or something like that
and I was in the boy scouts.
There was that thought like,
hey man,
this could go fucking sideways anytime
we're in the woods with some dudes,
they want to be in the woods with kids.
Like how well did they vet these people
see different.
Really,
I have to look at this,
write me that.
Are these people like legit boy Scout,
you know,
instructors or whatever they'd be who
really want to show everybody the way
the woods?
Yes,
most likely.
They're an,
it's amazing,
amazing experience for young men,
but just as human beings,
anytime you get human beings,
anytime you get a certain group of human
beings and you leave them alone with
large groups of kids,
Yo,
you gotta be super careful with what
their motives are and how they handle
pressure and how they deal with conflict
and how they deal with sex.
You know,
like what do you,
you know,
you ever molested?
Tell me when you were molested,
what happened?
You know,
like these are,
these are,
right.
It's a weird issues when you're talking
about dealing with children,
dealing with them.
The youngest ones are eight and 10 they
had see mine mind 70 10 yeah,
I mean it's just,
it's a weird time when you're watching
little human beings evolve and develop
and you know,
it's her,
most of it.
Let it go to,
you know,
like for me,
and I know for what the analogy you just
had was perfect.
It is really like summer camp.
But it's funny how it like,
you know,
from the day you're born,
the day after somebody else's stem
summer camp starts at,
it kind of kind of generationally goes
on forever and you kind of like realize
that you're stuck in this like movie in
which that you have to try and do the
best.
You know?
Like for me it's like do the best with
like your family,
the people you love and then like have
the most fun and do like do the most
damage in a good way.
Like they,
by the way,
all the people out there in the summer
camp counselors that are mad at me right
now,
this is now,
I'm not saying you're worried about
that.
You feel bad that the vast majority of
your awesome,
we're just talking about just in general
human beings is the sheer numbers of
human beings.
If you get a certain number of people,
there's a certain percentage of those
people that are going to be a problem.
You know,
this is the problem with cops.
It's not,
it's not.
The cops are bad people.
So when you say fuck cops,
you're crazy,
you're going to need cops.
Okay.
If something goes wrong at four o'clock
in the morning,
you want the more,
and who has the courage to stand there
with
a bulletproof vest and shoot at the bad
guys?
It's the,
it's the,
you know,
sam a Sam,
what's his name from three billboards,
you know,
it was such a good role.
You know,
I'm talking about that movie three Zam.
Who's in Sam?
Uh,
comedy.
So great.
Yeah,
he was,
he did not see that workers guide from
the gallon.
Oh,
Sam Elliot.
No,
no,
no.
We loved not Sam Elliott.
Yeah,
that's a good one though.
Sometimes the gardens,
you know what else he was in hitchhikers
guide to the galaxy was a great movie
called Joshua.
He was a z,
Z fod beeblebrox.
I read over and Jimmy Three Bobo,
they'll words.
He's,
that role is amazing.
And he's,
he is the moon.
Did you ever see that?
Oh yeah.
I love it.
We always kid.
Did you,
have you met buoys kit?
No,
the Dunkin Jones.
I've never met him,
but he's,
he's awesome.
That movie was awesome.
Is that what it's called?
The Moon?
Yeah,
that was great.
I met him because he was dating,
uh,
Leslie Bibb.
Yeah,
they were dating back then when I worked
with her in a movie.
Uh,
I did,
uh,
Kevin James Movie,
zookeeper with her.
I was her ex boyfriend who a douche bag.
I saw that fun,
fun movie do.
She's super cool man.
You want to talk about someone?
It's funny that girl [inaudible] nights
with her,
they hang out.
Oh,
that makes sense.
She's super fucking cool.
Really smart too.
But I'm at Rockwell.
That was the thing that I really got to
me like a dude,
that movie.
Yeah.
I mean it's fucking amazing.
That movie moon.
It is a movie.
This is,
this is how unusual this movie is.
There are no other actors.
I know.
It's amazing.
Sam Rockwell through the whole movie and
it's a march and didn't,
didn't Martian fields emotion feel like
kind of like a diet and then when you
saw it,
well I felt that way even though I
didn't cause it was different because it
was more about the hazards of
colonization and without the
psychological align with this movie,
I can't give anything away because it's,
this movie is a mind fuck at the end.
It's great.
It's a mind fuck the whole way.
It's a mind fuck.
I said,
Jeez,
Diet Martian I or I thought the Marsha
was the diet man.
Maybe I thought it was just another,
well listen man,
this is nothing wrong with like doing a
take on someone colonizing another
planet.
We have to be real careful about that.
No,
no,
no.
Was,
it was a book and everything just for me
in my,
in my eight year old movie going and
seeing in person,
I was like,
man,
it's,
it's good.
But when like moon,
I know there's a problem with,
uh,
people are scared to do those fucking
space movies,
do some more goddamn space moves the
plane over here.
I Watch Alien Covenant Again Five Times.
Actually every plane flight I take,
I already have them downloaded on this
fucking iphone and I watched promethium
and that back and forth.
You should go to jail.
Alien Covenant on it.
I know,
but you know what?
I got it.
It's there.
I don't have to add the Internet and I
have to pay for it.
If it's on thing I'll watch it but like
you ever used an apple TV.
We stream.
We fall into that too.
That's incredible work.
What a lot of work takes two swipes.
I know,
but look,
I feel like that that alien covenant was
such a fucking good good.
They like canceled or something.
I heard that he was had another one
alien awakening which is supposed to
deal with the time before after per meet
the US and into alien.
Kevin's supposed to be the ship ride or
whatever and I'm like and that they were
going to shut it down and crazy.
I here's what happens when we get to a
certain level of money.
When you're investing in those kinds of
films threshold.
There's a threshold and though,
because there's so expensive to make,
there's so much CGI and so much chaos
and special effects and an alien
covenant had a great fucking plot too.
I mean everything was great that it was,
there's so many twists and turns and the
aliens were terrifying.
They explained them.
I mean there was so much to it.
It was read a fucking good.
The finger on the pipe prometheus's for
a lot of people was less than than what
they wanted.
That's how it wasn't.
There was a bad movie.
I really liked it.
I thought it was fantastic.
They were setting some shit up and it
didn't do that well.
And we are spending,
I don't know how much the fuck they
spend on those movies,
but they're super,
super expensive.
It's one of them,
I mean aliens to as James Cameron,
like blade runner level shit in my
opinion in the sense where like at first
it doesn't seem like it's a massive
thing,
but it's just like for life it's that me
is fantastic.
And the question that it opens and the
second piece where I got to shout out to
blake judd cause he said,
hey man,
you're going to see it but you're going
to leave and you're going to be mad
because you can have way more questions
than before.
And then I told the same thing to sturge
Joel.
He was like,
I'm about to go see covenant.
I was like,
dude,
you're going to be mad.
I wasn't mad at all.
No,
I'm just saying cause I want to see the
next one.
I want to know more.
Right.
You still don't know the engineer thing
they see did,
that was just one of their planets like
our planet and they seated and they went
there.
So you're like,
the next one should,
or,
or at least like the finishing story
they said they wanted make it world war
of the worlds kind of thing where it was
like all of a sudden these people
descend and it's the two opposing kind
of parties,
which is the David side and then maybe
us extending onto the engineer's planet
like finally and it's all of a sudden
these two opposing forces,
you know,
so like I think that's brilliant
writing.
It's fucking fantastic.
When you got to realize is that movie
the original alien?
It goes back to 1979 with sigourney
weaver when she was as hot as the
surface of the sun.
They got the she running shit.
She's the original feminist Superhero
Gorney weaver,
[inaudible] original Badass woman in
movies,
fucking up monsters.
She's the original.
All these other movies that came
afterwards though the whether they're
fun,
you love em resident evil type shit or
who was that?
Kate beckinsale chick was a vampire.
I saw those underworld,
all those
super bad ass chicks in movies.
They all,
oh,
sigourney weaver.
She was believable,
man.
She's a scientist,
a scientist or whatever the fuck her job
was on that space ship.
And she was the only one who lived that
movie.
Spoiler,
it's 1979 trudeau has seen it.
But in that movie they were worried
about artificial intelligence.
That's amazing.
Hr,
Giger designed all that.
She had this space chalky it you stop
and think about,
they were worried about artificial
intelligence back in 1979 and that's
like when you talk to Elan Musk,
it's like one of his primary concerns.
No,
he's supposed to do the podcast.
I was in his physical presence at the
UFC,
but I didn't get a chance to communicate
with them.
He was with his lady,
but we had been going back and forth
through email,
so it was extra weird.
Um,
but I,
I'm,
I'm working,
you know,
when I'm doing the commentary,
man,
I'm trying to be,
I don't want to suck.
People get mad at me.
I tried to do my best.
I've tried to focus.
I can't go,
yo eat these fights are crazy,
bro.
There's no really real room for that.
But he's worried about artificial
intelligence more than anything.
And I mean this,
you're talking about a super genius.
It has an electric car company,
a rocket ship,
companies drilling holes under the
fucking ground.
He sells flame throwers.
I mean,
get the fuck out of here.
This is the guy that's worried about
artificial intelligence.
We should be paying attention.
And if you go back
too,
by the way,
there was an article,
well,
I want to say it was the La Times that
compared elan musk to Donald Trump.
It was like one of the most click baity
articles.
They're fighting for their lives out
there.
Man.
These fucking journalists,
they're fighting for their lives,
good for them.
They've got to get those clicks,
got all tangled up in this thing.
Um,
your chain man,
uh,
I'm,
I love guys who are crazy and ambitious
and make shit like Elan Musk,
whatever is happening with them.
The fact that he's like,
oh,
whatever,
I'll figure it out.
Let her just let it go.
Get it yourself out.
That's what's amazing.
As soon as you let it go,
that's how high you are.
And you thought you were tangled,
you ain't tangle like an example free
bro.
You got to break free and these change.
Um,
no,
I just like guys,
you know what,
I'll talk about spiritual for a minute.
I have to shout out to my,
uh,
the,
block tronics crew.
My,
my antsy artists,
I was talking about computers and bbs is
in block tronics or a antsy artists
group.
They're great.
That sturgeon,
it's so cool to watch him come up and
he's like,
got this kind of angle it like,
it's makes me,
I just love watching him on your show
and I just have to say us hanging out
and everything all these years later,
he just has a sense where I feel like,
wow,
there's a rocket ship in this universe
and we kind of speak the same language
and it's like a cool vibe.
Um,
kind of having another dude out there
who,
who has the same sensibilities and like
when we hang out,
you and me and him and everything,
I feel like it's,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I know what you mean about a mother
fucker.
Yeah,
no,
I'm honored to be his friend too.
Yeah.
I'm honored to be your friend too,
man.
For Real.
I'm honored to be your friend and you
took me.
I came to go see you play and you took
us in and then Dave Chappelle played
right after.
You're like,
Oh yeah,
hey,
uh,
my friend,
Dave's going to do a thing and then you
killed it and then he killed it and that
was crazy,
man.
That was awesome.
We're all lucky to know each other like
it's fun.
It's fun to know cool people,
but a sturgeon has got some new shit
coming out,
man.
She shared some stuff with me,
sent me some,
some images and explain what he's doing.
I can't wait to hear it.
It sounds fantastic.
It's going to be a why he sent me
[inaudible] can't see you can't say
nothing about it.
I'm on fucking here.
I accidentally leaked the title of his
last album I accidentally gave.
He sent it to me in advance and I put it
up on instagram and I said this new
sturgill Simpson Shit.
It's off the charts.
Yes I did.
I didn't know.
And then he's like,
dude,
you fucked up.
Oh No.
And he was laughing.
He thought it was fine.
It looks like it.
Just let people know about some of the
awesome early,
but I was listening to it in the gym and
a while I was listening to us in the
middle of sets and I was like,
God damn,
this is good.
And then I just,
I got to instagram this shit and like
instagram that I didn't know.
Hey,
that's cool dude.
You did the same thing with my old
records.
You're like,
you put a,
you put a picture of it up of your,
you just like screen grabs.
Yeah,
no,
I like to do that,
man.
I was listening.
She ate it.
Oh,
hey man,
I appreciate your music for real.
Thanks.
I was,
uh,
in um,
Italy and I was about to workout.
And then you know how you just,
you know,
you have those I phones without that
little,
um,
the cord with a button.
You could press the button.
Oh,
you start playing whatever you got on
your iphone.
It just goes right to Kool moe dee.
I go,
we'll work.
You know that song I go to work but at
band I'm going to work like a boxer.
You know?
It's like,
it's a great,
like I go to work song some about to
work out and this fucking song comes on
almost like the universe is letting you
know,
look dude,
just,
just don't try to think this through too
much.
Just press that button.
The songs there,
I don't know why it's there.
You don't know why it's dairy that
stopped thinking about it.
Right.
But it's there right when you needed it,
that songs there.
But at bat I go to work and then you go
to work it like it's weird.
This is it.
This is theater.
This whole thing is theater in some sort
of strange whatever cat.
Yeah,
there's some,
there's some part of life that's
seriously theater,
right man.
I mean it,
it,
to me the older I get,
I just feel like the more appreciative
for,
for like my dumb herself for having
gotten through it without more damage
being done.
So at this point I'm,
you know,
like I just really appreciate everybody
who puts an effort into the city into
life.
You know what I mean?
So you're like,
you feel like somebody is doing good.
It's like you,
you just,
I don't know.
It's like you and this show and how like
you've had this awesome career and then
I only met you the first time when I
came on this show and I like smoked pot
in the parking lot and I was like kind
of out of it.
And I was like,
oh.
And I came here and didn't bring a
record.
That's why this time I was like,
I had to make sure we had a record by
record.
It's called shooter.
It's out now.
I have to say something.
I didn't talk about it all,
but John Hensley,
Mary,
my manager back then,
he called me and said,
you didn't even talk about the record
once.
And I was like,
shit,
I don't know man.
We just got talking.
And it was,
I mean,
that's how it is with you,
you know?
But I love doing that with you because
it's like I'll go down the rabbit hole,
man,
I'll be on the algae at all and I think
people are scared to do that.
I think don't use anything wrong with
having thoughts.
I said we've got to stop yelling at
people.
Gotta stop yelling.
I think this,
there's the anger that we expressed
towards each other.
Forces anger and return when it's not
always necessary.
Sometimes it's necessary.
Sometimes you see Nazis in
Charlottesville and you've got to go,
hey you dumb fucks.
Like are you out of your fucking mind?
You really want to categorize people by
race.
This is 2018 you've got to stop.
This is some stupid shit.
I think the positive look at all of that
is the numbers of those kinds of insane
people have dwindled to a point cause I
remember when I was a kid and there
would be like still clan people and
stuff and that's just the argument for
free speech.
The argument for free speeches.
Ultimately it'll figure it out and
analysis out.
Yeah,
it does.
I think it does and it doesn't totally
because let's just be completely honest.
Some people do a terrible job raising
children and these children go out into
the world and they're just causing
damage everywhere they go.
They're on fire and they just run it
through dry bushes their entire life,
right?
They're creating chaos and it's from the
what set them off when they were young,
how they evolve.
They expect everyone to have like the,
the same starting point and be judged on
your emotional behavior,
your,
your impulsiveness,
you know,
dishonesty or your discipline to be
judged on those as if you all started
from the same spot on the board is just
crazy,
right?
It's just crazy.
And this is part of what we do.
We judge based on results only and when
we see someone to fucked up,
we don't go,
okay,
what happened to this person that made
them so fucking crazy,
right?
Like is it really their fault or Zeros?
A series of events that lead to you
being who you are right now.
And maybe we should remap it.
Maybe we should remap it and just look
at it in a different way and say,
look,
we definitely don't want that result
again ever.
Right.
We've got to figure out why you got to
that result.
What made you break into the bank and
put a gun in someone's face?
I mean,
how did you get there?
That's true.
It's like Manson said in the bowling for
Columbine.
He said,
they said,
well would you say to the columbine
killers?
And he said,
I would ask,
I would ask them their opinion cause it
seems like nobody asked them their
opinion.
You know what I mean?
So like yeah,
I asked him what the fuck happened.
Yeah.
Are they both dead?
They're both dead,
right?
Yeah.
Can,
it's tough to ask them their opinion.
I mean it's like,
you know,
make a love song,
but you know,
the reality is someone who,
who broke like what made you break.
We've all broken in little ways in our
lives and sure all lived through it and
we all appreciate other people who have
done the same thing.
And when you get to a point when you get
old enough where you realize you can
watch when someone is having a moment
that they can't make it through,
that you've kind of been through in ways
you kind of find it,
you know?
Those are the kinds of people that I
like that that will go and talk to that
person because they can see that and I
think that you're absolutely one of
those kinds of people because I've
actually had conversations with you when
we were backstage at the fucking comedy
store or wherever we were wounded that
night happened.
We had a conversation,
I don't quite remember the whole thing,
but it was about music and about
listening to music and it's like you're
a compassionate dude and people who
that's,
that's all it's about compassion.
It's about compassion and stability.
It's about recognizing the best times
come when we're nice to each other.
If you go to a bar and there's a bunch
of strange dudes you never met in your
life and an hour later you guys are high
five and then laughing and hugging each
other and you're buying rounds,
that's a great time.
Or you can go to a bar and someone wants
to get a dick wave and competition.
Next thing you know you got hit in the
back of the head by a chair.
That's possible too,
right?
You know both things are possible.
You know when one feels way better.
The one that feels way better is the one
where you meet,
meet a bunch of new friends and then
these guys you never met before and now
your buddies and then you realize like I
just ran into a fucking bunch of awesome
dudes who are now some of my favorite
people ever.
And if I didn't go out that night,
who knows what would've happened?
Just randomly ran into a group of
amazing people and change the course of
your whole life.
That's possible too,
man.
But we got to be that friend at the bar.
We got to be that new friend.
At the bar and the more people it's
possible to do that,
man.
And I think a lot of it is just the way
we think of each other.
There's a,
there's a problem in our operating
system or we have a ultra competitive
operating system and things we shouldn't
be competitive in.
There should be.
Then I think part of the reason is we've
lost a lot of competitiveness in life.
I think people were competitive in life
in ways where there's fighting for their
survival,
right?
They're fighting neighboring tribes the
most brutal and primitive of days.
Azure media.
Yeah.
And then as things changed and move
forward,
that got less and less physical and more
and more mental in the body got
frustrated and I think this is part of
what's happening along the way.
And then people started looking for
competition in business.
You ever hear like Weirdo business guys
talk,
we're going to fucking stuffed our
contract right up there.
They get all crazy.
Like they're starting a war man.
You know,
like super hyper hyped up business guys.
Got My competition has always been
disparaging me,
which you know,
all those jerks about my past,
you know,
they get fucking so that they want to
kill the competition.
Those people are weird bed.
They're weird.
They're focusing on it the wrong way.
There's some some dinosaur shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's,
well that's the money thing.
That's like if you're in the money game,
yeah.
But you don't have to do that to be in
the,
even in the money game,
you don't have to do that anymore.
Like I,
yeah,
you're right.
But I mean,
but if you do,
you know what I mean?
Like you do something you love,
you pursue angles.
Like you chose to pursue lots like
similar to me where it's similar in this
way.
Like you've chose to pursue all these
little different angles of the universe
that are in the entertainment business,
but they are also like things you love
like the UFC and then,
and then you know all the different
little,
I mean you've,
you've had so many different little
angles that you've occupied land up here
where you get to just talk about all
this shit that you love.
It doesn't make sense.
Even to me,
I wake up in the morning,
like today I wake up,
I go and work out and I'm sitting there
going,
what am I doing?
I'm just looking at this place shopping.
What's fucking awesome?
It's crazy.
Like honestly,
I wake up in the morning like,
how'd this happen?
You have an archery thing.
I would have old computers and that wall
and I would have like a pinball machine
and a bunch of old arcade games.
I have my own taste,
but like you got,
honestly,
it's,
it's a,
it,
you have found your path and,
and it's awesome and you're
compassionate and you're here and you,
you weren't in it.
If you were in it for the money,
you'd be somewhere else.
You're in it for what you like to,
didn't even know what I'm doing.
I don't know why minute you're talking
for me right now.
[inaudible]
second warning,
you're going to be a great dad and then
you're going to go do what you love to
do and come home and,
and that's awesome.
I just do what the great magnet compels
me to do.
I'm,
I'm merely metal filings moving through
the universe and credit towards the
great mascot metaphysical Neri,
Magna last 10 sure I made,
I've decided,
one of the things I've been thinking
about recently,
especially over the last,
like maybe 10 years of my life,
I've decided way less things that I did
in the [inaudible] what I need to seems
to me things just sort of happen.
So,
you know,
first the Bob Seger thing,
I moves,
I just tried to make some fun travel.
Yeah.
My,
my kids excel past me are ready all the
time cause yesterday,
I mean they trick me and they do things
and they're smarter and there and you
know,
nothing I could do could impress them
more than what they can do by watching
what I can do and doing it better.
Well,
how about when they do,
they fucking grab electronics.
They figured out.
That gave me that you don't know how to
do it.
She got to go into settings and you go
to here and you're like,
what?
You're eight.
Can you do this?
My daughter programs,
the log off in minecraft you can program
these blocks blocked.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I have to shout my RC people.
Oh yeah.
Our,
you still use IRC?
Yeah,
I'm still,
do you have a ham radio in your backyard
is a BCR my record label that I owned
with Adam,
uh,
there's a BCR IRC.
What does that,
the dcrs black country rockets,
the label that put out this records on
Electra through lcs and,
and uh,
Dave Cobb,
his label.
Yup.
There we go.
Uh,
I keep looking at the cameras that are
not this place.
It's too freaky.
Used to have the cameras on while we
were on but it's too weird.
Hard to be yourself.
Um,
I think they were on actually last time
cause that was too weird too.
Freaky freaked everybody out.
Especially when we'd started getting
high.
And you're like what?
This is not right,
but we have a thing called a know the
BCR bizarre DOTCOM BCR be a z a r.com
and it's like a place where like fans
come and they talk and we have an IRC
server.
So there was one all day and I'm on it
all day and I talked to Pete.
So ridiculous.
You just gave people that out.
Now people are going to go there.
I hope I welcome please.
I used to do a CRC back with my quake
days.
Oh yeah.
Great way to communicate.
Like teams would communicate with you
like server addresses are all going to
meet up at that show is free as fuck.
The inner,
the government didn't even know how to
fucking trace a phone.
Literally like listen in on IRC back
then.
Like they had to pick up from the
hackers.
Like how to do it.
That was a very,
very different thing when those,
all those message boards and all those
things came up like uh,
especially like the ability to,
we play games and talk to people in real
time during the games.
[inaudible] I'm one of the ways I've
learned how to type was from learning
how to type in game play quick cause you
got a tight quick quake one or like
quick what was known and what was it?
Started with quake two,
quake to multiplayer could wake one.
I mean I was in doom so like when quake
one came out and I was nine inch nails,
my favorite band ever and Lynn went back
then and still was the influence for me.
Like he did the soundtrack.
I think I was a moldy shit.
Amazing.
It's funny that all these years later
she's like,
I didn't have a computer but I went and
bought that sand because Trent reznor
did it cause she was into nine inch
nails and I'm like,
it's so hot.
Oh she has the CD of it in our house
still.
But anyway,
man,
I loved that and I used to do that too.
And once the Internet came on,
I had a friend in Nashville,
me and my buddy James and Greg,
greg,
this guy ran a bbs and he bought a doom
to server back then where you had had
four phone lines and modems in it and
dial in 56 k days.
Totally.
And we would play doom two and listen,
I was listening to like um,
White Zombie Astra creep 2000 as
probably 14,
13 just jam and this shit out man.
I was such a nerd.
Still am man.
If you saw my house,
you got to come over some time.
But I've got like my office is like 1993
we watched laser disks,
we have like old computers and like old
shit everywhere.
So it's like I kind of,
it's kind of frozen in a a weird
technological phase that I love.
That's hilarious.
That's awesome man.
Yeah,
you've always been like really into like
weird Internet type shit.
Like he really ended the
cryptocurrencies and there's a thing
called peep,
peep,
peep eth.
It's on twitter or whatever.
But it's,
it's a twitter alternative.
It's like,
it's,
it's just,
just starting that.
It's interesting.
Peop e t h e t h.com is the thing.
It's,
it's like kind of like twitter,
but it's built on the back of the theory
them.
And so every tweet or I'm going to have
a calling them tweets,
I should call it.
What are every message that you send on
it?
Kind of like twitter is embedded in the
blockchain of etherium.
Well,
this is to explain what this site says.
It says the values platform.
Hold on.
What did you do?
So we just uh,
a blockchain powered social network for
our best selves.
Yeah.
Well it because you can't delete
anything because it's permanently
embedded in,
it's like,
I think up to 10 of your messages can be
logged in one block of the theory and
chain.
So you have to pay like a cent of it,
but they give you some to begin with.
And then when somebody messages you,
it's kind of a metric microtransaction
to you.
So you have this kind of balance.
It's going all the time.
So do you have to open up an account?
You get a sense you can do it without
any involvement.
But the way it works is because it's in
transactions on a blockchain and
ethereum,
it's,
it's permanently lodged in this
permanent digital ledger in which that
these transactions are what's making it
happen.
So like if you'd,
you log in and verify yourself,
they give you like 30 cents because that
starts you out to be able to just kind
of permanently do this end.
So you don't have to do any,
it sounds complicated but it's cool.
I'm not saying I don't,
I don't know if it will become like the
next rage,
but it's technologically,
it's a really fucking fun.
Might be launching it right now.
Go back to that page again and expand on
the right hand side where it shows you
all the different categories and the
different values,
but make that a larger social media
bringing out our best with opinionated
features and immune immutability.
Hmm.
Yeah.
How often do you hear that word?
It's permit.
I mean not the ability to not mute.
I believe immutability.
So you can't mute people.
Okay.
Co we'll need to google that in a
moment.
Contact is openly and forever accessible
on the ethereum,
blockchain and ipfs,
whatever that is.
Thoughtful.
It says permanence and creative
constraints.
Encourage,
mindful and self aware.
Peeps.
They'll kid that was like a Haiku.
What does it that's like a fucking poem
and let some of this fucking thing
under.
Listen to this.
Again.
Permanence and creative constraints.
Encourage mindful and self aware.
Peeps.
That's okay.
Is I just stumbled across it,
but I love it.
I love the technology.
I do too.
But I mean that was,
I don't understand what they just said.
Uh,
charity be responsible.
Charity badges prevent suffering and
inspire others.
1000,
178 mosquito nets purchase so far.
Oh that's amazing.
So they're making their purchasing
mosquito nets.
Now that that has to do with the,
uh,
the actual platform.
I think it's not a real mosquito net.
Don't think,
Oh,
I
thought responsible matt to this
website.
I have no,
they tried to do her thing.
Okay,
well they are there.
They're buying mosquito batches to
prevent malaria.
I'm getting paged cause they ain't go to
Conan.
Oh,
it's over.
I know.
I don't want it to mark.
I don't want it to be over either
shooter.
We've gotta do this again.
Yeah.
I led them on man,
and uh,
I'm,
yeah,
I'm glad you started off that
controversial subject of the Alex Jones
thing.
And I'm really glad that Bill Maher went
out on a ledge and said,
you know,
even if you don't agree with someone,
you're not supposed to silence or
speech.
You know,
I just don't think people were supposed
to be alone yelling into the wilderness.
I agree.
This farther mentality,
you know,
is a problem.
Even him,
I don't think you're supposed to be able
to do that.
I don't think he's supposed to be alone
yelling off into the abyss.
My wife's calling me now because he's
telling his club.
Everyone's freaking out.
Everyone's freaking the fuck out.
It's just time,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's a way of measuring distance.
Thank you for having me to jennings your
shit.
I love you too,
brother.
A shooter.
It's out now.
She are Janie's outcome this,
uh,
this shit's vinyl,
old school son.
Respect all.